devrait passer trois heures tous
ensemble pour parler de la draft nba
2021 plein d'invités ils connaissent
bien la nba viennent pour parler de la
franchise qu'ils veulent on leur a
demandé
je vous explique le principe ensuite on
déroule il arrive soit avec une question
chaude soit avec une hotte take donc une
ode quest you know in not take sur leur
équipe
un avis tranché et en face on aura bien
sûr les membres de l'équipe l'envergure
pour discuter de la draft on prend vos
réactions également dans le tchat sur
youtube en réponse aux tweets qu'on va
poster sur le conte envergure n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à notre chaîne
youtube à nos podcasts aller sur
envergure point c'est au tout ça tout ça
on a plein de scouting report on a plein
de contenus sur la draf donc c'est parti
on accueille d'abord à l'année ben les
draft punk salut salut les gars les
avant gardistes exactement pour la
première franchise qu'on va aborder ce
sera ce sera les pistols donc il ya enzo
de detroit pistons c'est à compter de
fer qui est là comment tu vas enzo basa
merci beaucoup d'invitations et est
vraiment un honneur de représenter le
compte des trois pistoles france
et toi ça va quand même bien mieux
depuis
depuis la loterie je rate on est on est
content même si on a des frayeurs le
choix non mais c'est bien tu crées du
tour et du suspense havas et y réagit
déjà bastien de trash talk
si vous connaissez la nba en france vous
connaissez probablement la tête la voix
les articles tout ça tout ça merci pour
l'invitation c'est cool merci les gars
encore pour tout votre taf tout au long
de l'année sur un mercure surtout quelle
plateforme c'est un plaisir venger merci
à toi
j'avoue que ça faisait longtemps qu'on
nous disait pourquoi vous faites pas des
trucs trash talk bouillet des
commentaires sous le truc pourquoi vous
faites pas des trucs draft avec
envergure et l'a jetée propose et a dit
oui dans la minute
les choses sont simples les choses sont
belles
on va parler de détroit pour commencer
donc enzo quelle est ta oat tec ou
quelques questions chaudes vas-y alors
la question que je vais soulever ce soir
sera est-ce qu'on doit s'attendre à une
année de gros temps king com s'est passé
cette saison la grippe stones ou de
l'évolution dans le contenu de notre
saison est dans la finalité
ça c'est une belle question alan j'te là
je te la souveraine en premier est ce
que avec take du temps où avec kate tu
joues les play offs et ça en gros déjà
tu es à l'est
donc c'est pas pareil que c'était à
l'ouest je pense est ensuite qu'elle
fait un genre je pense que c'est tout le
graphe je lui donne le ballon tu donnes
le ballon il va avoir des
responsabilités je pensais à côté
l'effectif n'est pas dégueulasse non
plus il ya quand même des joueurs nba
dans ses effectifs
moi je penses que tu peux pas tant qu
est certes encaissé quoi avoir des
quatre pires bilans de la ligue parce
que tu veux avoir le plus de chances
d'avoir le choix numéro un je pense
qu'avec peut-être koenig âme
à l'est c'est pas possible
personnellement je pense que c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose d'envisageable
dis pas que c'est bien
peut-être que tu as envie encore d avoir
un autre choix dans top 4 deux ans de
suite je te mettrai peut-être très bien
sur les dix prochaines années mais je
pense pas que c'est possible
bastien qu'est ce t'en penses avant de
donner la parole à ben je pense que
c'est très particulier je pense que vous
l'avez vu avec la avec l'implantation du
pays tournament
c'est très difficile maintenant de voir
les différences entre le top 10 et le
reste c'est à dire que maintenant le
bottom faut vraiment être une équipe de
merde pour être dans le fin fond de la
nba à l'ouest et à l'est
je pense que à detroit demain tu tues tu
démarres le camp d'entraînement et on va
voir évidemment comment ça se passait
parce qu'il ya des jeunes de talent et
ce terme et je pense pas qu'ils vont se
mettre des objectifs de dingue mais je
pense que tu peux te dire objectivement
ouais on va on va faire de notre mieux
mais ne pas s'étonner si on peut se
rapprocher du pin tournament ça va être
intéressant je pense au cours de la
saison de voir comment tu te rapproches
parce que sur une saison normale à 82
matchs si tu te retrouves en février à
la 10e place
genre charlotte avec la figure
historique on a vu la dernière ou des
huitièmes qui dit être qu'on va jouer in
en tout la draft
résultat tu y es et peut-être que cité
des 3 etc tu es 11/12 bon alors on va
pas se faire chier on va faire comme on
sait bien faire depuis des années je
pense que tu le sais enzo on va perdre
des matches de basket et on va se
ramener la loterie donc je dirais en
deux temps je pense que ça va jouer
compétitifs parce que moi je suis un
grand fan de kate que nous y sommes
mais à mi saison je pense que la
rencontre sera enfin détroit alors c'est
intéressant ben le la question aussi
c'est l'impact de kyle cunningham sur
une équipe on va peut-être rappeler
parce que tout le monde ne suit pas la
saison nba et les saisons lycéenne avant
qui est kate
quand même qu elle prospecte tu vois
qu'il est parce que là on parle comme si
c'était acquis que c'était le mec qui
allait faire step up la franchise alors
qui est il
c'est ce qu'on appelle un initiateur
grand format là c'est un gars qui a le
physique pour jouer un poste 3
smartphones mais qui joue vraiment un
rôle de meneur spears est peut-être de
quoi 238 je m'excuse avec mes données le
système métrique ici parce que je sais
que c'est pas la même chose en france
mais coiffé deux mètres 1 et 5 kilos en
plus puis il est fort physiquement il
était blessé au même que son athlétisme
est vraiment prêt on est pro on n'a pas
encore tout vu ce qu'ils étaient
capables de faire sur un terrain parce
qu'il joue à l'intérieur de ses moyens
présentement un siège à montlieu jamais
demandé vraiment de se dépasser et de
taille de quelqu'un qu'il était forte de
dépasser ses limites
donc il est capable de driver il est
capable de passer il prend les bonnes
décisions sur le terrain un aspect que
j'aime beaucoup de quelqu'un et gamme
qu'on apprend très peu ce soir se jouera
très calme
ce joueur qui dimanche sous contrôle d'à
peu près tous les situations et aux
shoots il est pas mal du tout non plus
il est fort mal du tout une fois une 30%
bon voyage sur deux tiers de poules donc
[Musique]
s'est jetée dans la lah n'doua compte
souvent sur les ondes de radio c'est le
type de joie le plus recherché albis le
profil de joueur ne peut pas chercher
enzo qu'est ce que t'en as tant qu'aide
après tout ce que tu as lu est ce que tu
sais pas si tu es allé voir des matchs
etc
mais qu'est ce que tu attends qu'il
apporte aux pistols et peut-être aux
autres joueurs de l'effectif aussi
puisqu'il ya ça quand tu draft quelqu'un
de haut tu fais aussi augmenter la
valeur de tes pièces complémentaires
alors ce que j'attends de lui cédait ce
vraiment le cas qui peut te renverser un
match c'est à dire une opposition serré
ils attendent de lui plus prendre feu
mais tu puisse prendre le secourir sur
cette époque est assurée j'ai regardé
des extreme de luis da ilha et des
matches tous et vous vous dites il me
trompe mais moins m'a beaucoup fait
penser par moi un débit de booker dans
ses mouvements dans sa façon de prendre
la balle de d'être libre et de faire
steve avec la balle un peu ça me fait
beaucoup penser à lui et j'attends un
peu le même rôle qu'il a eue depuis le
début de sa carrière
phoenix c'est à dire l'étincelle celui
qui va vendre pouvoir te fumer un match
c'est à dire le match est serré sous un
coup de chaud il peut il peut finir le
match
est ce que j'attends de lui d'un nouveau
collectif ça va être surtout de bien
jouer avec notre français qui anaïs est
de pouvoir un peu l'été dans les king
parce que kinatay c'était un peu
questionné dans ce dans ce compartiment
du jeu cette année et je pense que
l'addition de quelques une gamme pourra
l'aider dans ce sens là et surtout pour
les théâtres développer un jeu au
football si une des volontés de bonnes
qu'ici pour la semaine à venir
bastien juste c'est ssekate ces caïds
c'est sur ces 100 % sur aux parents un
ouais après j parce que jeudi soir mais
moi perso si quelqu'un a une gueule
n'est pas pliée en un jeu quitte le chat
quoi ça c'est vraiment vraiment un
sketch de chat parce que
en fait je sais qu'il ya après je veux
bien justement la vie de tous les
copains qui sont ici mais c'est je suis
assez assez étonné de voir qu il puisse
y avoir un débat j'adore jane green est
vraiment evans mobley et il ya des
garçons qui pourrait faire des très
hautes aux côtés barnes a un potentiel
assez lee cornélien danse dans ce genre
de la nba et moderne je suis assez
étonné parce que enzo tu fais des
comparaisons avec avec des bimbos coeur
qui sont à mon sens aussi très vrai il
ya quelque chose d'un petit peu de c2c
folle en kit impose son rythme et tu vas
rien faire en fait bien eu des
comparaisons design tatum aussi en
termes de un peu de formats comme le
disait ben qui a pas du tout de même
type de jeu mais qui est un peu folle en
ou en fait tu te fais avoir sans que tu
en sois trop en décompte genre et un
call mauvais match de quelques ligaments
en 21 points 6 rebonds et 5 passes et en
fait pour moi il n'y a pas vraiment de
débat c'est le numéro un de cette draft
je m'étais exprimé sur le profil qu'on
avait fait en disant que pour moi
récemment c'est un des meilleurs
prospects
qu'est ce que c'est que ce commentaire
qui a tout cas à titre personnel j'avoue
que je suis dans le wagon les yeux
fermés félicitations les pistols
il faut le prendre et quelque part même
dans l'histoire des pistols s'asseoir et
et des équipes collective très bonne
avec des stars mais certes c'est surtout
le collectif des années 2000 de coty les
années 80 il ya peut-être une superstar
qui va arriver et j'y crois juste je
serai en fait plus étonné que quelques
gags ne soit pas all star en troisième
saison en nba il le soit pardon je
l'étais mis en mieux que oui la
classique / côté caïds ou pas s'est il y
en a 10 à 2 commentaires de suite sur
côté cailloux pas alors c'est peut-être
une question qu'on se pose pour de vrai
s'il ya deux questions de suite à la mpt
d'asie non non pour arrêter pas parce
que il est n aie puisse pas parce que
tout le monde l'a couronné comme numéro
1 de drogue depuis deux ans maintenant
et depuis qu'on l'a vu ba au lycée à
mondevert donc on l'a vu dominer avec
team usa alors qu'il est surclassé deux
ans donc on l'a vu tout le temps est le
meilleur en fait on l'a vu tout le temps
être le meilleur
donc non il est pas surcoté
tu sais quoi être sûr côté c'est sûr
côté par rapport aux autres numéros and
rave des années précédentes où est-ce
que c'est sûr côté par rapport à
d'autres joueurs de sa de sa propre
cuvée je sais pas trop comment il n'est
pas sûr côté c'est celle un mur genre de
la draf c'est le meilleur prospect
depuis le cas dont 6 décès de mon avis
personnel
donc pour moi c'est une meilleure hausse
paix depuis depuis que depuis doit être
quatre ombres et donc non une des trois
fait pas de mauvais je vois des trois se
prend un joueur qui est capable de
passer dribbler shooter le shoot s'est
tenue cette année en fait le shoot
c'était pas trop il y avait deux rondes
pourcentage aux lancers francs mais
tellement bon physiquement qu'il
arrivait à dominer tracy était plus fort
et parce que c'est d'abord un pass first
kate serait vraiment un pas ce first
avant et sa qualité de passe on garde
quelques matchs d'oklahoma state on a
comprend très vite
d'ailleurs c'est pas son ratio passes
décisives turn over n'a pas été trop
aidé par ses potes qu'on pas trop mis
les paniers dans les coins nous n'avons
pas mal de leur sort est un peu
différente
ouais enfin sersou côté ça donne quoi en
défense ben avant de redonner la parole
à bayt com comme la taxe doit toujours
jouer à l'intérieur de ses moyens il n'y
jamais vraiment été emmené à ce déjeuner
vue frustré quelquefois des fois
abandonner certains joueurs mais je n'ai
jamais vu ce fait j'ai vu tous ses
marchés
alan souffrir physiquement
alan dans le chat en outre on joue à dix
mais meilleur que zion c'est la réaction
parce que tu as dix meilleurs prospects
depuis dans le cherche alors plus facile
de construire mon équipe si je vois les
autres titres autour d'eux un profil
comme kate que dirions-nous fait pour ça
en fait que je donne l avantage
j'allais poser une question d'ailleurs
alex juste mais le sait le c'est planète
rap dance plaisent à jouer poser une
question parce que c'est un aspect qu'on
avait abordé récemment je voulais bien
vous
est ce que est ce que le fait que ce
soit pas un joueur aussi spectaculaire
que d'autres jouent sur sa cote c'est à
dire qu'on est sur un joueur qui a un
style tellement particulier qui ne va
pas te te renverser comme les ien comme
est déjà mort hante comme tous ces gars
là est ce que parfois on a tendance
aussi à prendre les piques
waouh c'est des people à la fois sont
productifs mais qui en plus de rendre un
peu dans les étoiles j'ai l'impression
qu'avec caïd en fait on dit oui il a un
peu surcoté parce que en fait ils
ajustent les meilleurs appuis la
meilleure lecture de jeu les bonnes
rotations défensives
il est calme comme suit a dit ben il
sait comment faire c'est un peu je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez
bah c'est pas un athlète plus plus c'est
peut-être la seule chose que c'est il ya
c'est peut-être le seul truc à chaque
fois on dit sur kane un peu plus en plus
négatif parce que aucun procès n'est
parfait aucun procès n'a jamais été
parfait et qu'il doit il n'est pas il ya
parmi des énormes swazi des trucs qui
ont misé en thomas comme tu l'as dit où
il n'y a pas un premier pas super
dansant qui va faire qu'il va pas de son
son adversaire facilement mais en
réalité et c'est une autre forme de
domination une autre forme de domination
c'est déjà dans un mode fait des
lectures très avancé une appréhension de
jeu de très bonnes
donc comme je dis c'est peut-être moins
spectaculaire qu'un déjà mort hante qui
va mettez des gros faceà à me restait
toulouse aion qui était un peu
l'attraction hyper athlétique qu'on
connaissait depuis longtemps ça c'est
intéressant ce crédit parce qu'en fait
moi quand je me balade un peu sur
réseaux sociaux offerts à mesure de la
saison les jambes il me parlait beaucoup
plus de diane greene qui me paraît de
quelques dégâts mais s'est pas trop fait
déjà une graine et les connais depuis
très longtemps
diane greene si on suit un peu les
comptes puisque et overtime les comptes
comme ça sur instagram
ça fait quatre ans qu'ils m'aident et
aux marques sur tout le monde en a
écoulé qui l'est c'est aussi un très
très bon joueur fibre donc ça ça joue
aussi je pense peut-être pas raison dans
le délire sur le côté ou su côté
dernière dernier article de johnatan
giffoni sur espn on apprend qu'il n'y a
que kate qui a work out pour détroit
sinon il y aura deux noms ya john green
voilà et d'après ski ressorti à 20 pour
le premier pic 1 il ya sans doute des
prospects second tour oui vraiment
d'après ce que ressorti tout d'abord du
work out de kate sait qu'il n'a pas été
aussi convaincant que cela lors du work
out alors que au contraire via les grimm
a impressionné beaucoup de gens et c'est
justement ce qui fait un peu semer le
doute dans le front-office des pistols
treiber qui dans tous les cas sera le
déshonneur du choix lui et 500 pour qu
ait une gamme mais on sait qu'un à
certains qui eux préféré avoir jane
green mais c'est pour ça qu'il ya peu le
tout qu'y qui est un peu aussi comment
dire alimentée par les médias pour un
peu peur le suspense et tout mais en
soit le je pense clairement que kate
sera sélectionné qu'on va passer dessus
on appelle ça du leverage 1 pour faire
croire qu'on va sélectionner quelqu'un
d'autre et faire monter les enchères
derrière en disant tiens à les roquettes
se faisait déjà laine gris nez bas vous
allez payer un petit peu pas si je si je
peux rajouter que je parlais du second
tour labonté de troubles hiver c'est
aussi d'utiliser second tour pour
pourquoi pas monter avec un pic au
premier tour ces limites des fontêtes
ruyver hans adore ça ça serait
intéressant mais alors la fin de premier
tour début second c'est ça peut partir
n'importe où injuste en deux mots ben
vraiment entre les prospects de 20e
place et 2 50e place il ya pas d écart
fou quoi ça va se jouer au coup de coeur
ouais je voudrais poser un mode grave
avec un autre site je m'en rappelle pas
de casquette il ya quelques il ya
quelques jours et des ja des prospects
ont un look l'accès à 12 ou 13e qui ont
signé au deuxième tour c'est vraiment à
partir de 20 c'est vraiment une question
de qui on aime qu'il bon feeling avec
lui et j'ai trois postes sommes
inquiètes ça ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas invité à dire si le nouveau
à celui de l'année dernière ils disent
nous a toujours après la bagarre tu as
assez
le classique les coups durs et alan
juste on a une question dans le chatt
quelle configuration autour de caïd est
d'abord enzo qui va y avoir qui l'année
prochaine à detroit alors aujourd'hui on
vient de sortir l'info que hamidou
diallo il fera un jackson sont restés à
jet
donc du coup je pense que les pistols
devrait s'aligner sur l'offre et les
garder tous les deux parce que les deux
ont été bradées bons éléments
cette année on devrait également avoir
ice à la mène en titulaire et donc qu'a
t on fait en deux d'un côté et sadique
ben et jen ai appris au poste de pivot
ça dépendra ça dépendra de si on veut
lancer stewart et dépendra de surmont la
retenue ou pas mais je pense que
l'association icescape sera inévitable
ça va bouger bastien jusqu'à la free
agency detroit ou pas j'ai envie de dire
que là en novembre dernier en fait
malheureusement le running gag enzo il
le connaît on espère qu'il y aura passé
quatre pivots qui vont être signés en un
quart d'heure par les pistols parce que
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur l'arcade
jeunes si je pense que c'est une bien
enzo à mais j'ai l'impression que la
route est prise par des trois est
vraiment celle de la basse lance la
construction il n'y a pas de rush on a
envie de trouver la bonne alchimie il ya
aussi des garçons qui monte des
premières bonnes bases mais on sait
aussi qu'il ya une différence entre
montré des bonnes choses dans une équipe
qui crainte ou une équipe qui est
productif donc voir quelle année 2,2 et
ce soir je sais aussi que c'est triste
mais avec le deal que vient de signer
jérémy grant qui a pas non plus été
énorme et avec aplomb qu'il a fait il
est tombé dans les rumeurs de transfert
c'est sûr donc on va on va on va
surveiller mais je crois que les pistols
ont vraiment donné juste du temps à ce
groupe
d'ailleurs assez content qu'il ait dix
doigts une question regarde ce que je
pensais qu'il y avait un nouveau gm ça
aurait logiquement indiqué un nouveau
coach mais je pense qu'ils vont juste
démarré camp d'entraînement avec le
groupe qu'ils auront en voyant ce qui
n'est pas de produire et ils auront une
meilleure idée c'est vraiment le serment
de l'auto en ce moment un peu des trois
c'est de voir si les tests clé joe
jackson
jalil okafor je sais pas ce que vous
avez fait comme tu es ce que le client
n'en mais c'est un peu dingue donc
ça me met plus d'argent c'est pour quand
j'en parle parce que je voulais revenir
justement de quelles sont les ambitions
du front office et juste du coaching
staff treiber il a été clair en
conférence de presse
une saison à une vingtaine de victoires
c'est pas que c'est à l'ac thann et
parce qu'à quelques pas ce que valait
tant qu est ok mais là il prochaine il
veut être beaucoup plus compétitif et
surtout avoir plus de deux victoires
donc ce qui va primer au pistone ça va
être premièrement l'alchimie du groupe
parce qu'il a aussi dit qu'une de ses
priorités
ça serait de créer un collectif qui
grandit en simple et deuxièmement aussi
avoir la mentalité pistols match de
peace of mind 7 c'est à dire se battre à
tous les matchs jusqu'à la dernière
minute et sa présence un gars comme
hasard tu vois c'est l'exemple parfait
disputant le du pit en 2007 qu'on veut
voir son terrain et prochaine réaction à
la enzo on peut signer une cataracte des
knicks on peut signer capte gros
bonhomme et chapelles bien tourné au
prince
après est ce que est ce que les gros
bonhomme de le signer chez les pistons
parce que j'ai regardé l'adapter agency
premièrement allait pas hyper hyper
intéressant en ont comparé aux deux
années et le non plus intéressant que
moi j'avais s'était démarqué rosa est
aujourd'hui bien d'y jeter un oeil qui
pour gagner
donc il viendra pas mais après après
aussi il faut le savoir il faut savoir
laisser le développement aux jeunes et
donc les gens ont besoin de temps de jeu
forcément donc des vétérans donc on a
corrigé aux herbes dans l'effectif
actuellement
on hamm est simple oubli des vétérans
comme ça qui sont pas forcément we know
et qui peuvent aider les jeunes à
développer on les prend tous les
journaux donc si on va avoir des
signatures comme bénéfique pour alan la
conclusion ça sera la réponse à la
question des nz hauts du début
combien de victoires pour les pistols
l'année prochaine je vais tous vous
posez la question préparée
non mais ça ouais mais ça dépend si
caire entre entre
28 et 30 et trois ans on aura tous les
records dans un entre 28 et 32 et juste
sur la construction d' équipe rapidement
des shooteurs déçu angie parce que c'est
un genre de drive in teak donc c'est un
joueur qui va pas pu en fait à initier
accéder facilement au cercle
parce que ben il avait la peinture était
tout le temps resserré donc pour qu'il
faudrait pourquoi pas des shooteurs dans
les provinces a dit b est un super
joueur je pense qu'il peut même s'y
alignent tonnes est toujours sur le tour
de leur corps roster l'an passé c'est un
mec qui peut jouer et qui peut aider
et puis oued et intérieure qui pose des
écrans qui vont vers le certes fort et
pourquoi pas un mail interne qui peut
pop et aussi donc qui peut tirer à trois
points bas de la modernité un peu de
modernité au tour de kate s'est lassé ce
qu'admet affaire je pense parfait 28,32
tu as dit ben tu dis combien de
victoires
6 quai d'où toute l'année jusqu'à 37
victoires puis les yen tourne maintenant
la neuvième ou la dixième place moi je
suis je j'ai l'impression que quelqu'un
en gamme et un joueur qui change une
franchise qui rend tout le monde
meilleur et que qu'il y en a de toutes
nouvelles vocations
il va devenir des meilleurs joie était
déjà bien meilleur joueur africain
grosse pas beaucoup soir qu'il connaît
gamme comme toi qui change le destin
d'une franchise
il ya une très belle hype en ville
autour de caïds écrit bryansk je sais
pas où il vit mais doit vivre au même
endroit que toi ben puisque tu as l'air
eyed peas pour revenir sur le
commentaire il a totalement raison
j'écris un article récemment sur ça et
toute la ville une veut que kate et kate
est allée en ville à detroit une semaine
pour faire ces entretiens la confronte
aux finances teixeira
ça a été la star de la ville pointe
semaine c'était fou languenan cas pour
quelques unes gars à des trois séries
c'est un truc que rarement bien pour moi
que j'étais ailleurs des horizons crié
son nom est tout de beige pour ça mais
même qaïda dans la ville même lui a dit
qu'il veut être une icône de la vilenie
star du tapis alors vas-y bastien la
communauté trash talk attends ton
pronostic pour le non
de victoire des pistons l'année
prochaine oh [ __ ] alex perd 6 t'attend
trente et une victoire trente et une
victoire tu peux en gagner 10 de plus
que ses horaires d'été à 20 victoires tu
peux en gagner 30 31 on attend de voir
c'est dur aussi de se projeter quand
t'as pas la free agency les instruire je
suis les bonnes signatures et je te
rends compte que ils ont un banc plus
profond que ce que tu imaginais non moi
là je suis très intéressé c'est que tu
portes quand une victoire mais je veux
bien voir la gueule dans le management
des caves ou des bulls cité pas très
très loin d'eux qui eux sont en
construction depuis un peu plus
longtemps
oula tu dis merde en fait ils sont
beaucoup plus avancés que nous alors
qu'on a des stades différents et j'aime
bien ce genre de franchise qui change la
politique humaine parce que je ne vis
pas avec les hawks voilà on va en parler
dans quelques secondes pour le programme
de la suite aura aussi parlé de golden
state on va parler de nos petits
français on a des indiscrétions des
choses à vous révéler notamment sur les
work out de roanne begarin du côté de
d'envergure et puis et puis à mi
parcours de ce live
dans une heure on aura un quiz et à la
fin une mode draft express c'est à dire
qu'on aura 20 secondes pour faire un pic
et bam bam bam bam bam
on va envoyer de la mode draft enzo
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci pour
l'invitation est juste pour donner aussi
mon style du coup abbaoui évasive et
supermarchés a même pas demandé quelle
quelle impolitesse
je vois je vois banks optimiste pour la
saison à venir
mais oui mais franchement comme un dieu
bastien une trentaine de victoires ces
joies et comme il a dû aussi sa voix on
verra surtout berlin all star game où on
en est et où est ce qu'on va y aura
aussi la trade and key qui serait apparu
je ne sais pas si j'ai la migraine va
faire ce qu'elles sont avec nous pas
donc il ya plein de facteurs qui vient
de sortir est énorme le micro regarde
live
il a dit je vais quand même leur donner
du grain à moudre prof nana na na na en
gros ça trois joueurs
dans la discussion pour le pic numéro un
on reste sur le leverage pour moi ce no
way s'est remis l'hiver tu peux
augmenter l'offre des roquettes
merci au revoir exactement
donc il dit juste quelques ning engine
green evans mobley source is tél
espn voilà adrian wojnarowski merci pour
les choses qu'on savait déjà
merci enzo tu la donnes est aux
pronostics ou pas j'ai pas noté oui tout
juste une trentaine plus tard voilà bon
vous mouiller parents franchement
dépassé les 41 m diplômé comme a dit ben
me semble aussi qu'il hadji qui l'a tant
que cas ils prennent les choses en main
et ça vous à voir que ce talent et déjà
le coaching partie très réticents à
faire beaucoup mais liu qui donc je vois
pas pourquoi on prendrait le risque de
cramique de blesser quelqu'un une gamme
qui va jusqu'à sans doute les 82 matchs
ne faut pas faut pas s'attendre à le
voir dépasser les 25 minutes par match
comme ça donc à voir ce qui pourra
porter avec ceux d'angela absolument
merci beaucoup merci encore une fois
enzo 2 contre detroit pistons et faire
du site aussi bravo pour votre votre
boulot votre couverture de la franchise
franchise quand même qu'à une vraie
histoire est une vraie identité donc
c'est très très cool et puis et bien
reste avec nous dans les commentaires si
tu es un peu de temps avec plaisir pour
parler de la suite on va accueillir
pierre notre spécialiste des prospects
internationaux qui est flouté flou
pierre ça va quoi au koweit
est ce que tu es dans ta voiture est
dans ta boîte j'ai besoin plus génial
j'ai l'impression de voir les il ya qu
elle prospecte a fait une interview dans
sa voiture si tu as lu ming
je reste convaincu miniac exception
pierre on va on va parler des prospects
français dans quelques minutes et je
peux le dire maintenant on va avoir
notre ami elliott qui bosse chez les
people et donc qui va pouvoir nous
donner alors évidemment il n'aura pas
leur dire grand chose d'humain zune sur
la draft des pistols mais il va pouvoir
aussi nous donner son sentiment lui qui
bosse dans un staff n'diaye sur les
français qui se présentent à cette draft
donc c'est quand même pas mal joué à la
ja y repense je vienne begarin qui sont
les trois noms les plus cotés que du
côté des français bastien c'est ton tour
tu parlais d'atlanta finale de conf
voilà mais un choix de draft quand même
qu'est ce que vous allez faire c'est
quoi ta oat tec ou ta question chaude
vas-y bay le truc c'est que atlanta donc
vu la saison qu'ils ont fait qu'ils
étaient un petit peu surestimé par
rapport à ce qui avait été prévu on va
pas se mentir il ya des besoins réels et
mao tech c'est est-ce que travis link va
enfin foire est un pic de draft depuis
son arrivée et plus sérieusement
évidemment sur les besoins qu'il ya
évidemment à la mène en back up de
triangle donc avec des sharif cooper
déjà couleurs etc ou bien on continue à
empiler les ailiers 6 8 6 nine their
williams pour prendre peut-être la place
de kaboré dit chan sais pas ce que ça va
donner par la suite ou deux garçons
comme ça donc que vont faire les hawks
entre remplir la baignoire pire les aide
parce que je pense pas que ça
t'intéresse la question donc plutôt
plutôt sur les postes 1 de plutôt sur
les postes 3 4 sachant que les dernières
indiscrétions de jim o'neill je crois
que c'était lui aussi disait que que
soit qu'ils aimeraient dit choix dit
andres enter allait partir en gros
qu'ils n'allaient pas pouvoir payer tout
le monde m jean le cam reddition oui oui
oui c'est plus le bizarrement il ya qu
un nom qui ressortait ce genre on va se
débarrasser d'un ailier mais vous n'êtes
visiblement ses cadres est dit alan déjà
qu'est ce que tu penses du fait de ba de
laisser partir cavendish qui a montré de
belles choses
est ce que ça vaut le coup en fait c'est
ça va être une question un peu
philosophique mais ce que ça vaut le
coup de remplacer un mec qui sait déjà
un peu formée par un autre mec qui est
moins une bière est né du coup puisqu'il
a deux ans de moins
nba dans les gens font c'est compliqué
mais moi je suis moi aussi j'aime
beaucoup atlanta très engagé mais c'est
une de ma première victoire de draft
donc un vigile lui devrait beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses donc il est beaucoup
dans mon coeur je pense que non moi je
pense que moi je suis toujours un pape
du talent au dessus du fit donc je me
préoccupais pas de cibler un poste déjà
du côté d'atlanta je prendrai même en 21
même quand on sait les playoffs et ou
non si hazard williams qui descend je
prendrais williams tous les jours de
vent mais qui pourrait entre entre
guillemets aider tout de suite à un
christ duarte un cor et cri qui se
portent ces trucs là je vais vers le
talent à revendre sur kaboré dit chez
moi je lâcherai pas la même à rudy et je
lâcherai pas qu'à vrai dire très
honnêtement ça reste un joueur qui est
dans sa 3e saison qui a mené au départ
pas mal de soucis de d'efficacité en
première année mais qui a été surtout
blessé j'ai trouvé cette année en
deuxième année et donc il ça reste ça
reste un talent top 10 d'une draft
toujours dans son contrat rookie dans la
deuxième partie de ce contrat ou qui
donc je pense qu'en plus si jamais tu
veux le trade et sa valeur à l'est pas
au max maintenant ok il a fait des bons
freins bouts de matches contre milwaukee
mais si tu veux très dès que tu penses
qu'il n'est peut-être pas dans ton futur
et que tu préfères faire le choix d'un
hunter peut s'avérer normal parce que
hunter moi je te dirai qui et il avait
vraiment pris une super belle en un
superbe envol cette année alors que
c'était pas mon prospect préférant 2009
qu'il était au tour avec la il a été
extrêmement impressionnant mais moi
j'attendrais un peu je pense je
prendrais meilleur joueur disponible
dans 20 et sur cambridge je le garde
pour l'instant
et si jamais oui ça se passe mal ou que
j'ai besoin d'aller chercher peut-être
un vétéran à la deadline de la saison
2021 2022 parce que j'ai besoin d'un
joueur peut-être pour m'aider pour les
play-offs là je peux lâcher mais pas
maintenant
ben on a là la petite liste
ddd prospects vu par les hawks
officiellement il y en a eu plus
probablement en work out qu'est-ce que
ça t'inspire jayden springer crise
duarté à zahia jackson john preston est
notre amie brenda tout cas ce que je
suis un apologiste fini de jeunes
espagnols et je crois que si on peut le
mettre à dans post 2 à côté d'un tuyau
ou de le mettre à la mène en
remplacement du triangle vous qu'on
gagne absolument énormément et côté par
un psy et meurent ou vrai je vois mal
comme il ya un talent un meilleur
terrain disponible que ça moi je crois
que dans ma dernière moi que j'étais à
tod
un hoax moi j'aime beaucoup ça je me
fous la compatibilité russie avec le
l'effectif qu'ils ont à atlanta mais
comme ils sont ils sont 1 ils sont un
contrôle de leur destinée les accises
ont voulu ils ont plusieurs sens
plusieurs possibilités ils ont dix sont
des bons joueurs aux postes clés dans
qui va nous acheter un triangle qu'une
capello même jusqu'à un certain point et
peuvent être quatre donc il a lyon la
barotte choisi william battant parce que
des jeunes spectateurs acquis à la prime
à l'auto mais rien de springer tu prends
thomas bastien tu prends tu prends
direct je devais moi je suis très fan
dans les dents les espèces de coups de
coeur notamment parce que john springer
je pense vous en savez mille fois plus
que moi sur ce qui s'est passé à
tennessee mais j'avais été suffisamment
farfouiller pour voir ce qui se passait
avant sur le circuit inférieur lorsqu'il
était en confrontation avec des garçons
comme quelqu'un une gamme comme jay leno
suns où il ya eu des affrontements ou ou
c ou c'est kif kif en fait
mais après les évolutions sont
différentes mais moi je suis un très
grand fan de james bond girl je pense
que même s'il ya des grosses hésitation
normale sur son shoot il ya un combo
défense compétitivité attitude et
capacités de finition et pénétration qui
est de jeu à mi distance
enfin en tout cas de shoot à mi distance
qui m'intéresse pas mal donc
moi je suis très fan mais en fait c'est
pour revenir sur ce que disait alan
c'est c'est juste que cam raidissement
jeunes quittent absolument pas le bateau
et dieu sait s'il faut pas le quitter
parce qu'en plus c'est la contrepartie
du deal dans le site
on va pas se mentir lorsqu'il a eu
l'occasion d'entrer en plus le pic 10
mai s'est jusque là quand je moi
personnellement je ne m'attendais pas à
ce que thierry novateur phase des play
off pareil et je pense que notamment
dans le management d'atlanta ils se sont
dit jean bouin en fait c'est un mec qui
nous a complètement éclaté il ya une
semaine à philadelphie c'est un mec qui
a été drafté en 18 je crois ou en vain
par un travail et qu'à l'époque pareil
sous estimer développé en interne donc
il ya un moment où si bogdan bogdanovic
france est une là et qu'il faut garder
kevin walter il ya quelqu'un qui va
lâcher si tu viens john collins et
indiens de renteria quelqu'un qui va
lâcher si monique et au congo qui est
formulée hier qu'une cape et agressive a
lâché et j'ai peur que pour cam rédige
ce soit compliqué et qu'en fait ils
explosent dans une autre franchise parce
que comme l'a dit alan le talent est
indéniable et qu'il faut juste qu'il
trouve sa place en fait alors pierre toi
qui suit les prospects internationaux
est-ce que 1,5 ghosn aux hawks s'y
glisse est-ce que tu le prends il ya ben
qui fait les gros yeux
moi je pensais plus à d'aruba peut-être
qu'on pourrait retrouver dans 60 jours
oui c'est plus sereine j'ai
effectivement même si ça va bien mais ce
n'est pas encore sûr à 100% de la wii va
tomber et dans une équipe qui joue un
peu vite
je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment la
place la place de son groupe et on en
parlait la semaine dernière sur le
parquet des sonos est ce qu'il va être
prêt pour jouer en playoffs à nouveau
les minimums des conférences destinées à
la conférence effectivement bastien tu
as tu connais un peu les prospects
internationaux qu'est ce que tu fais ce
que tu as à dire j'aime beaucoup le fit
guère le bas par rapport à l'hexagone
parce qu'en plus j'ai après je sais pas
vous est ce que vous les avez trop casey
mais j'ai l'impression que si seng wun
quittent le top 15 ya en tout cas une
intrigue chaboud
après je sais pas où vous l'avez placer
1 vous l'avez sur des ballons ça dépend
des gens on va dire faut qu'elles savent
exactement 15e je crois moi que j'ai
dans le top-15 aussi je ne vais pas au
premier tour d'accord bon au moins chère
nation sur les sur les prospects
nationale après moi j'aime bien
évidemment disons que c'est ce qui s'il
y en avait un que je devais prendre
parmi tous ces avoir un bon centre de
formation pour josh qui vit parce que
j'aimerais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup avec bébé majuscule
voir ce qu'il peut donner dans une
franchise qui sait bien le faire
travailler
je vais pas vous mentir que j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'ils tombent aux spurs en 12
parce qu'il ya eu plus d'un shooter qui
a question travaille à san antonio et
qui est reparti avec un poignet bien
bien raide donc de tous les prospects
internationaux
j'ai un énorme coup de coeur pour le
juge qui dit devant les autres mais je
crois qu'il sera jamais en vain chez les
autres je crois que ces bulles
l'unanimité des modes draft ça va pas
passer le cut du 13-14 johnny dit très
probablement donc donc cessé après j me
sens qu'on parlait de monter je me
rappelle plus j'ai lu plein de choses ce
matin de 1 an de prendre un autre first
run pixi ont trait de cadres et dish moi
c'est ce que je me disais en préparant
les missions que dans le cas où tu sais
toi par deux organismes
pourquoi ne pas laisser le trader à un
pote je serai des plus assez de joueurs
pour arriver autour de 10 entre 10 et 14
et 7 produits dits qui pourrait
atteindre le top aux créateurs pour
tourner les minute pour souffler pour
sur cet aspect là très rapidement je
fais après sur cet aspect là le gros
coup de pression qui est mis notamment
par les propriétaires d'atlanta
c'est d'être vraiment dans le will now
ils ont été hyper content l'a devancé
avec les payeurs et donc il aime bien le
développement mais très très clairs
notamment vous l'avez pu la voir la
représentante des ostendais dernière
loterie elle a dit c'est la dernière
fois qu'on fait le tri et ça a été pris
très au sérieux et donc j'ai
l'impression que s'il ya un pic de draft
c'est vraiment on ne bouge pas et on a
essayé de l'utiliser ou sinon le col
dans un transfert pour avoir un vétéran
mais dans la tête des eaux qui sont
persuadés que c'est pas une équipe trop
trop de finale de conférence mais plutôt
de premier tour qu'il ya de chatouiller
des gens et j'avoue que moi j'aimerais
bien avoir certains pros ce pas mais je
me demande moi ce qui s'intégrerait en
sortie bande déjà que on s'est préparé
le caillou dans la gueule lorsque sonné
ko kangoo a été piquée en six sets je
crois la dernière par les autres s'y
soit si c'est ça et j'avoue que là
dessus moi je suis très confiant après
parce que onyeka à montrer quand même de
très belles choses sur sa saison rookie
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu
le demain et que les hawks ont beaucoup
dans le maintenant intéressant
ben et alan pour conclure sur les hoax
votre choix idéal pour pour la franchise
de bastien après je te posera la
question bastien c'était la question de
base est ce qu'on va choisir plus du
dollar hier plus de l'ailier votre
prospect idéal bene alan votre fille
idéale aux hawks qui sont donc plus dans
le winner
sinon il va avec mais bryant n'est dans
le mémo le qg d'un espagnol peut-être un
peu moins physiques lan qui va rentrer
dans un rôle tu veux qu'il va accepter
son rôle doit jouer à l'intérieur d'un
rock simplement mais intéressant c'est
ouvre pour ce qui est projeté pour lui
mais c'est intéressant
le choix du fit jouer tout de suite en
mec qui s'en tire tout de suite très
murphy de virginia lorsqu'il sera au fil
faufilant en deux secondes je poste 3-4
très bon shoot en catch and shoot
défenseur très intelligent doté d'une
belle envergure est donc vraiment bien
il est sur ces postes là qui joua rice
avant de transférer à venir
n'y a donc qu'un cursus un peu différent
mais qu'un joueur qui connaît une belle
cote et si on veut aller sur l'obs hyde
jetty tort de o'byrne parce que en plus
des temps des gens est le plus jeune de
la drogue je pense que c'est un des
talents les plus intrigants et atlanta
bankrolls avec des avec des joueurs qui
savent jouer le pick-and-roll pourrait
vraiment bien le développer c'est un
soudanais d'origine qui joue à auburn
avec chérif looper en poste 4 5
né en août 2002 qui bat par flash tirs à
trois points et protège le cercle de mon
intérieur bastien vas-y tu me feras le
coeur dit jean springer ousir williams
mais parce que la vie est une fête et
qu'on a besoin d'avoir le patron pour
former le petit on va on va mettre
sharif cooper d'ailleurs très yang et on
va essayer d'avoir un bon back up pour
essayer de dynamite et tout ça sans bat
les couilles de la défense on n'a que
des six aides qui sont capables de
prendre la suite derrière en deuxième
rideau avec king capella et unique et au
congo donc s'il ya soit sharif ou peur
soit john sanders wazir williams qui
tombant en vain je suis très content
à titre personnel chars
ne doit pas tomber aussi bas mais
peut-être que j'allais dire si vous avez
si vous avez sharif et triangle en
équipe ça va quand même être un gros
coup sur le potentiel de soi que des
outils qui serait quand même injuste
pour les équilibres une belle pétarade
2.6 ouais tu peux pas faire jouer les
deux en même temps je pense enfin sauf
si c'est rick carlisle ton coach peut
être mais mais sinon c'est compliqué on
va accueillir
on va se refermer le dossier hawks on va
ouvrir le dossier
frenchy et on va peut-être parler de
détroit aussi un petit peu
bienvenue elliott de witte comment vas
tu merci merci merci de m'accueillir
ça va très bien merci et vous sera très
très très bien est ce que pour ceux qui
ne te connaissent pas tu peux rappeler
quel est ton occupation professionnelle
s'il te plaît oui donc moi je suis avec
les tractations ça fait maintenant un an
dans la vidéo roues mais aussi sur des
prêts au débat
et donc voilà donc bah comme vous le
savez là on en pleine semaine de bras
donc c'est extrêmement buzz y est aussi
excitant c'est assez drôle de voir tout
l'intérieur même si j'ai pu vivre celle
de l'année dernière malgré qu vide mais
donc voilà ça fait sept ans que jose
états unis maintenant et c'est ma
première année en nba avant ça j'étais
en l'université pendant pendant six ans
notamment à texas tech c'est ça ouais
elliott jeu évidemment si t'as pas le
droit de répondre tu me dit j'ai pas le
droit de répondre à ça tout ça va être
caïd du coup quoi bas pour le coup je
n'ai pas répondu tout pour deux raisons
la première c'est que j'ai pas la
réponse et la deuxième c'est comme si je
l'avais je pourrais pas là contre
maintenant maintenant dans la vie
personnelle privée jeu pour être
vraiment honnête sincèrement je n'en
sais rien quand je dis on je pense que
tout le monde dans le top 3 4 des
équipes nba on a tous vu le top 5
et je pense que voilà tout le monde se
fait un peu des idées par rapport à ça
mais ouais genou au moment de ce qu'on
entend de ce qu'on sait c'est que
généralement le top 3 donc nous houston
cleveland
même ton retour et orlando je pense que
tout le monde a vu le vraiment le top 5
juste pour avoir 20 c c'est très
intéressant pour toi c'est une draft à
cinq joueurs
alors moi je dirais à 4 parce que moi
j'aime pas déjà lenssens donc pour moi
car mon gala avant secondes mais c'est
mon avis personnel
ah ouais ça marche des facs comme ça moi
je parle pas en terme de piston je parle
en termes de moyens bien sûr après avoir
regardé cette année je dis je ne dis pas
que c'est un mauvais joueur du tout je
verrai jusqu'à mon gars plus en terme
d'impact direct en nba que ce guide mais
encore une fois c'est mon avis pour
plusieurs raisons mais c'est juste voilé
après juste une une raison vite fait une
raison de rapidement quand même on est
là poids je pense qu'au niveau de
l'apport athlétique défense et tout ça
direct et surtout de l'apport au bon je
pense que maintenant on est dans une
libye où il ya de plus en plus de small
ball est donc un manga en étant à 606
nine avec une envergure incroyables qui
peuvent vraiment défendre de rein à
quatre peut-être pas à 5 mai de 1 à 4 au
moins qui peut switcher essayer de
garder la balle devant lui pas encore un
shooter vraiment je dirais renommée
encore beaucoup de travail à fournir
évidemment mais je pense qu'il peut
apporter la sueur précise évidemment oui
et très adroit c'est peut-être son arme
première avec sa vitesse et sa vision de
jeu mais je ne sais pas moi moi autres
moi si j'avais le choix entre l'un et
d'autres jeux moi personnellement je
croirais comme une gare en tout cas
intéressant pour ceux qui viennent de
nous rejoindre donc elliott delà de la
vidéo room et prieur développement des
pistols et est avec nous elliot on
on voulait aussi parlé des français mais
je finis juste sur detroit k1 de choix
en début de deuxième tour dans cette
draft est ce que tu peux me dire qu'ils
vous avez work out ou est ce que t'as
pas le droit d'une somme que c'est à
moitié publique
si vous les voyez ces réseaux sociaux
est pas en parler si vous le voyez pas
je peux pas vous le dire normalement
verlag te dire qu' on a vu un bon bah on
a vu les comme jeudi le top quatre top-5
b2 du protoss et le tour je parlais du
deuxième tour est pour deuxième tour on
a vu on a vu une trentaine de joueurs
ok ça n'a jamais on n'a vu ouais c'est
extrêmement large on a vu plusieurs
européens et plusieurs frenchy
d'ailleurs et on a vu énormément une
joueur de niort s'était énormément
alors ok on va parler des frenchy l'on
va pas demander lesquels lesquels vous
avez vu il ya pierre qui avec nous qui
est dans la team envergure chargé de
couvrir les prospects internationaux
on va on va parler de johan begarin
alors j'ai deux trois infos a filé mais
d'abord est ce que tu peux nous nous
présenter son cv c'est intéressant aussi
pour pour ceux qui nous regardent
c'est pas un prospect à leipzig avec ian
ice café thé ou mal et dont l'année
dernière même qu'avait ses coups il ya
deux ans mais voilà c'est un joueur
jeune qui pourrait se faire drafté
qu'est ce que t'en penses quoi de johan
bégard quelles sont ses forces calé son
billet d'entrée en nba je pense que
évidemment son physique c'est quelque
chose qui a évidemment et encore des
choses qui peut rajouter mais je pense
que le fait qu'il ait déjà un physique
et ce qu'ils soient athlétique ça va
direct avoir un impact énorme le fait
qu'il puisse défendre et qui démontre et
ça avec paris déjà auparavant qu'ils
puissent vraiment voilà garder garder
des duels et tout ça parce que
maintenant une bille est vraiment il
quand t'es pas un frein de chasse où les
yeux c'est vraiment comprendre le fait
d'être un rôle player en fait et je
pense qu'il peut il pourrait rentrer là
dedans avec certaines équipes après
encore une fois la nba c'est un peu la
loterie aussi ça dépend dans quelle
équipe tu tombes et comme on utilise et
pourquoi et comment enfin bref
mais je pense qu'il pourrait je pense
que je pense vraiment qu'il a une chance
de se racheter oui complètement
avec qui lance à rien mais qui pourrait
avoir un impact ne serait ce que grâce à
son physique ce qui peut impacter quand
même un rebond il a quand même une
certaine vitesse il est évidemment
athletics donc il peut jouer il peut
avoir un peu là-bas dans les mains c'est
quand même un gros bac pas un gros gros
prize heures il peut quand même créer
puis le fait qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
au dessus du cercle aussi va apporter
énormément de choses et puis les super
jeune c'est l'un des plus jeunes je
crois que la draft et ça c'est un truc
que en nba il adore parce qu' il aime il
amusé sur le potentiel et sur l'avenir
donc donc entre guillemets c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être mieux de le
prendre tout de suite et de le
développer que de prendre un an ou deux
ans ou voilà onergie tout peut-être
après encore une fois on ne sait jamais
parce que ça dépend avec qui joue avec
qui s'entraînent comment ils progressent
6 me laisse pas fait le plein de choses
qui rentrent en compte mais mais c'est
vrai que voilà c'est pourquoi pas le
prendre tout de suite justement et et le
faire bosser et que et je pense que
voilà je pense que des joueurs comme ça
cdc des joueurs qui peut vraiment avoir
une carrière lingway tiers tu as
participé à l'essai il est il est assis
j'ai cru que tu étais allé d'art pierre
pierre tu as participé à un podcast avec
les légendes du club de paris l'a du
paris basket ball ou jouets johan
begarin et qu'est ce que est ce que tu
as pu avoir des infos sur un tueur
comment s'était passé comment il avait
ressenti son processus de draft ces
différents workout pierre ne m'entends
pas pendant ce temps là je peux vous
dire que il ya eu des work-outs avec
denver
je peux vous dire que denver l'aiment
bien ça c'est les infos que qu'on a eu
c'est je vais pas je vais pas vous filer
mes sources mais visiblement et elliot
si je dis une bêtise tu as le droit de
me corriger
j'ai entendu des nouvelles jantes en
aide aux équipes aussi mais bien sûr non
la vraie mois chez nous on a vu begarin
aussi ça s'est très bien passé
mais après fin entre guillemets pour
être honnête c'est très très rare ça se
passe pas bien donc ça s'est passé avec
lui tout comme tout comme avec les 30
euros les 30 autres études rappaz 30
joueurs donc ça ça veut tout dire comme
ça veut rien dire en fait absolument
mais visiblement ça s'est moins bien
passé aussi avec d'autres franchises
mais en tout cas mais en tout cas denver
la bien aimée et on rappelle que denver
à un choix en fin de premier tour donc
ça et il aime bien drafté des joueurs
jeunes des joueurs voilà qui sont
peut-être pas encore prêt mais qu'on va
développer et c'est donc un français au
premier tour s'est pas complètement
exclu cette année on était plutôt sur un
nom je pense que la probabilité reste
plutôt sur un nom d'ailleurs toujours
mais mais c'est quelque chose qui reste
une probabilité alan toi toi tu le
drafter est entre 30 et 40 sur sur ce
que tu as vu de bégard 1 cette année
ouais mais si j'ai plusieurs choix en
fin de premier tour ou que j'ai
plusieurs choix en début de 2ème et que
je vais monter enfin deux premiers pour
assurer les le contrat plus long et
sécurisée pour un type de joueur ça
pourrait être pour un joueur comme
jeanne dégâts matériels c'est un 2002 il
est jeune
le matériel que tu draft avec begarin
physiquement c'est au-dessus de la
moyenne donc peut te prendre te dire que
tu le prends tu l'amène dans ton système
nba je vais lui faire faire de la
g-league je pense pas qu'il sera stacher
comme d'autres d'autres aspects
européens je pense que oui ça sera pas
ça passera peut-être par plus forte de
la g-league ou par les choses comme ça
mais je pense que c'est un matériel
coûteux
toi qui doit intéresser en fait sa
saison en pro b elle elle était vraiment
crescendo il a été mieux sur la fin de
saison c'est un joueur qui nous avait
vraiment hyper impressionné très jeune
en fait il a été très fort très
athlétique très jeune donc il dominait
lorsqu'il était juste plus tranchant est
plus fort que tout le monde s'écoute
comme ses coûts à l'époque c'est ça et
après quand il a fallu jouer contre des
adultes ou essayez pas de dettes en plus
dans l'appréhension collective met des
tirs ce qui est passante pour un jeune
joueur
tout le monde pense que bas parce que
beaucoup de gens moi je pense au regard
des médias et donc ils ont les
pourcentages et une bille en tête mais
c'est pour des joueurs de 16 17 18 ans
tournait à plus de 35% à 3 points c'est
très difficile et j'ai surtout dans les
ligues professionnelles surtout dans des
petits tournois fibre à dévoyer des gens
qui me disent on me regarde les
pourcentages sont katawal mais sur six
matches tu shootes à un sur dix dans un
des matches après pourcentage délicate
et en fait il a fallu qu'ils apprennent
en plus ça je pense que ça s'est mieux
passé là en 2021 pour lui au paris
basket et il a prouvé l'accueil gillick
combine ça s'est pas trop mal passé je
crois et ensuite voilà il a le corps il
a le physique pour être drafté au
premier tour ça a pu lire absolument et
et sinon il ya deux autres équipes nous
de ce qu'on a entendu qu'il est qu'ils
ont vraiment bien aimé il ya les boules
ce choix 38 les kings le choix 39 et il
me semble que givonne il a 40 dans sa
mode draft
donc ce qui voudrait dire que ça serait
étonnant qu'ils passent le choix 40
on va on va le dire comme ça bastien
c'est c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle je
sais pas si tu as suivi mes gars c'était
plus plus anonymes là tu le regardes tu
passes déjà ta journée à regarder du
basket chez moi chez moi évidemment le
j'ai suivi ça de loin pour revenir juste
sur ce qui était dans les comparaisons
plus jeune moi j'avoue que je les plus
mais c'est vraiment très perso je les
plus éthiques t2 quand j'ai vu les tout
débuts de livres pons où c'était hyper
spectaculaire et hyper athlétique et
donc ça ça dominer comme tu disais à
l'instant elliott avec eux de brouilla
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de trop suivre
sanner ce qu'ils ont et moi en fait la
question je vois que d'ailleurs elle
était arrêtée sur le chat c'est ça veut
dire que selon vous il ya un espèce de
consensus sur le fait que s'il ya un
français qui est drafté en premier c'est
begarin devant yayi elliott vas-y après
est ce qu'on parle de quelque chose on
ne parle pas des niveaux que tu penses
et où on parle de voilà ce que le luron
entendu on parle on parle
est ce que ces bébés guérin en premier
qui sera apte et de la france en termes
de prospects ou est-ce que ces jeux est
la question
ouais bon mois ces brigades y'a pas
photo pour moi pour moi je pense même
pas cailly réseau sur drafté
malheureusement et je dis bien ça moi je
dessers d'un oeil français je veux
quelque peu de français drafté
évidemment
mais je ne serais pas surpris que joue l
ne soit pas grave tu es ah ouais ça
c'est intéressant c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait très vite urbania qui va pas
aller en nba attention parce qu'il ya
des liens sur dix jours keating juste
après mais je ne serai pas sûr parce que
faut pas oublier que sur 70 y en a 15 à
20 qui sont gravité mais qui reste en
europe
donc ça aussi c'est ça reste un ça reste
quelque chose à étudier mais mais c'est
possible qu'il ne soit pas drafté mais
qu'ils soient si après qu'ils se rendent
une équipe à 100% comme comme thil il a
fait l'année dernière
ouais je perds un contrat tout est ce
genre de choses voilà moi sur mes
begarin par rapport à eau prospère lajot
à ce qu'il va apporter la lâche c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très important
tu as l'air de tu suis ça fait plusieurs
fois que tu le dis bah second non c'est
quelque chose que peut-être les gens
oublient aussi quand il quand ils font
leurs évaluations c'est pour les équipes
nba c'est très important
oui je pense que ça une grosse
importance
je suis mis la chance de côtoyer
plusieurs general manager dans plusieurs
différends plusieurs conférences dans
différentes conférences et les divisions
de la nba et c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui revient souvent ses
amis l'a 22 ans amie l'a 23 mai il a 21
mai lula 18 par voilà c'est la princesse
conditions victor c'est qu'il est super
grand et puissant il a que 16 ans [ __ ]
il a que 17 ans c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose là je vois tout le temps
être quelque chose qui va revenir et le
fait que j'espère que je l'aï aurait eu
au ras une carrière comme jahren brunson
de villanova avec dallas par exemple je
lui souhaite je lui souhaite vraiment
maintenant je sais pas c'est très très
rare des gens qui restent quatre ans en
université et qui ont des grosses
carrière en nba quand on regarde ce que
moi dans ma conférence quand j'étais
être que c'est qu'avec franck messone de
kansas qui était un joueur
extraordinaire en université et qui
maintenant galère à avoir une équipe en
nba alors que c'est un joueur mais
extraordinaire joueur de l'année ou en
université tout ça et maintenant voilà
jane rhodes disparue joueur de l'année
en université en 2018 ou 2017 et leila
avec dallas pour lui par contre pour le
coup il joue beaucoup ma chance ça se
passe bien voilà je sais tout le mal que
je vais pas jouer le d'avoir une saison
afin d'avoir une carrière comme jane
bronson où il peut se faire drafté ou
sinon avoir un contrat derrière et
pouvoir jouer voilà des années des
années mais mais voilà encore une fois
je ne serais pas surprise
n'est pas appelée à la draft mais
derrière kissing je serais pas du tout
surpris et en ce qui concerne yves qui
lui aussi a passé quatre ans ils foncent
80 l'université profil de alors il a la
taille d'un 3 mai mais il va
certainement jouer plus + 4 en nba gros
grosse protection de cercle grosse
explosivité un trois points qui en
légère progression
un shoot en progression est ce que tu
penses qui peut être drafté je pense
qu'il peut être drafté ouais je pense
qu'il pourrait qui pour être drafté dans
les 60 c'est possible pour le coup je
pense que mes gamins passera avant aussi
pour le coup juste pour revenir sur un
peu le même débat tout à l'heure je
pense que mes gars en sera le premier à
se faire draft et six sur les deuxièmes
tours en tout cas mais il faut qu'on
soit parce que c'est c'est pas forcément
le même profil évidemment et le même
poste que hi hi hi pour le coup et puis
je pense que il a été son shoot et son
jeu face au panier a été vachement
andrew ladd donc vachement je suis comme
on dit en français côté merci et ce côté
je pense vraiment que voilà moi j'ai vu
beaucoup de matchs et beaucoup de choses
chez qui a beaucoup disent qu'ils ont vu
nous aussi on a vu et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui a été assez sous côté
que maintenant une fois que tu le vois à
l'entraînement et ça c'est quand même
des choses qui reviennent parce que
voilà évidemment le corps est incroyable
la son niveau athlétique et hors norme
voilà il peut sauter au dessus du
gymnase s'est passé pas un problème
maintenant c'est voilà est ce qu'il va
pouvoir qu'est ce qu'il va pouvoir voilà
m à l'extérieur est ce que je vais
pouvoir défendre sur lui ou pas ou est
ce que ça va être quelqu'un ou le gall
va tout le temps resté près de la
raquette parce que ça sert à défendre
sur lui là-bas à l'extérieur et je pense
que voilà c'est que c'est la grosse
question que les équipes se poser à
force de le voir dans les work out je
pense que c'est des voix là c'est
quelque chose qui sur quoi je pense
qu'il a beaucoup travaillé parce que
c'est vrai que ça n'a rien avoir de
connaissances l'insep
absolument bah écoute elliott je te
remercie d'être passé pour pour parler
de nos frenchies
ça fait plaisir de t'avoir vu et même
temps ce cet emploi du temps chargé
d'avoir pris quelques minutes pour
passer dans planète draft sur envergure
merci wiotte même dit remercier de
m'avoir accueilli et on vous souhaite
évidemment tout le meilleur pour les
pistols et promet key2key et moi je
viens du big toe à le voir donc je serai
confronté quelqu'un d'autre du beatle
qui viennent d'oklahoma state
mais ok je crois que c'est une décision
aussi moi j'ai écouté je fais ce qu'on
me dit ce sera la compassion
merci beaucoup elliott tout le meilleur
par la suite avec les pistes et nasri a
plus assez merci au revoir
ciao pierre honte à retrouver quel quel
retour tu as eu de delà des work-outs de
bégard un ace qui tend non donnés alors
de ton passage avec le podcast du paris
basket ball ils n'ont pas eu de retour
plus particulier que ça on m'a dit que
sans son profil était intéressé mais que
c'était quand même assez mitigé après
c'est sûr ce que ce que dit est ce que
c'est vous elliott sont il a un physique
qui est vraiment à hors norme et une
capacité à défendre sur au moins trois
postes qui a qui devrait lui permettre
peut-être pas de lui donner du temps de
jeu de sa première année mais au mois dé
drafté est ce que tu es ce que tu peux
nous nous parler des autres français qui
sont qui sont retirés
il ya pour pour qu'elles pour quelles
raisons rapidement peut-être pour ceux
qui nous regardent y avait pas mal de
pré candidats oui voilà pourquoi ils
sont retirés ce qu'on peut les revoir à
l'avenir quand un candidat à la draft
bas on avait match opposait kenny
baptiste qui évolué en championnat de
france
voilà n'hésite pas à me corriger s'il y
en avait d'autres je crois que j'en ai
oublié un autre
c'est vrai qu'on a plus vu que les deux
autres donc un yoann je pense qu'il doit
encore avoir un an des jeux lisibilité
il risque encore de il risque de prendre
encore du temps de jeu et peut-être de
passer première rotation à cholet comme
il l'a fait sur la fin de la saison
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils jouent en qui
joue une coupe d'europe l'année
prochaine
il était en baisser cette année pour
mathieu gosselin et pour match 2 1 et
que ni baptiste say on les a pas
beaucoup vu
on attendait mathieu un peu mieux cette
année ils étaient là il a signé au ccrb
à chalon il a pas vraiment réussi à
atteindre les objectifs qui avait tu sa
se donner en début de saison il me
semble que son temps de jeu a été un peu
un peu réduit et on avait mal comme
cazalon qui a fait que alan a aussi vu
pas mal je crois et qui a fait un début
de saison assez mitigée mais qui a
réellement exposés à partir de février
avec mes khaleq donc le club a de
l'ancien club de nikola djokic et de
simonovic est est rousseff qu'on devrait
retrouver l'année prochaine
et de louer au cabaret beaucoup cabba
qui a été excellent comme alan tu me
dises je me trompe il a on a vu vraiment
moi j'ai vu de vraiment un changement
déjà en défense à partir de à partir de
février je pense qu'il a eu un déclic
ils ont joué une sorte de coup par coup
contre le le pana et à partir de là il
commence à prendre beaucoup de minutes à
défendre beaucoup mieux et à mettre ses
shoots à trois points et il me semble
que jusqu'à la fin de la saison là on
comment on commence à le voir prendre
plus de plus de deux minutes de
responsabilités et il a ce qui sera
aussi sans son argument de vente ce sera
aussi son corps son grand corps c'est
quand bras
bah c'est le troisième larron de la
génération 2001 avec mal et donc il ya
des élus s'est formé un trio dans les
compétitions de jeunes
le problème de casamance et qu'il a pris
un peu de retard parce que voilà où
killian il a fait le choix de hull pour
se mettre en avant et drafté théo était
dans la sphère asbl à lui est un petit
peu plus galéré il a qu'il a été prêté
en france qui a pris l'avion en belgique
séparés en place et ensuite la il finit
à mes gars là je pense que c'est la
meilleure chose qui pouvait lui arriver
c'est une usine à prosper en fait tu vas
là bas cette année et chaque année il
met en avant certains prospects qui
permettent de en fait c'est un bon débat
en danse 1 qu'est ce que le
développement chez un jeune y en a qui
pensent que c'est de jouer l'euroligue
peut-être mais ça peut être aussi de
jouer 30 minutes dans un championnat pro
jeunes m'ont traitée dès ce qu'ils aient
des progressions et ça ce que c'est ce
que kazan tu pourras faire l'année
prochaine et c'est ce qu'a choisi aussi
hugo besson qui était aussi prêt
candidats à la draft mais on score de
pro b cette année il va aller jouer au
break up new zealand vrai que ce l'année
prochaine donc vous pourrez le voir en
hd sur twitch il va jouer avec ousmane
dieng qui était l'autre hippiques
français pour 2022 et c'est l'ancien
club de herjean qui se souvient
absolument les and the breakers on va
accueillir on va parler de toronto et
bastien je vais juste un mic qui va nous
parler de toronto n'est pas à l'image
dans la matrice actuelle absolument il a
choisi la pilule rouge pour lui bastien
juste toronto est ce que ce serait pas
le premier tournant de la draft parce
qu'on a l'impression que le top 3 il est
un peu on va dire fixer et puis toronto
peut-être qu'ils hésitent en fait entre
segré quelqu'un d'autre il ya eu des
rumeurs sur scotty bas récemment c'était
de savoir s'il pouvait monter jusqu'en 4
il ya un côté un peu tout droit avec le
fait de prendre les rênes seule chose
parce qu'il ya les incertitudes autour
de calories mais en fait le problème
c'est que peut on par l'incertitude en
parle au pluriel
à toronto on ne sait toujours pas si
masai ujiri va continuer à guider cette
franchise on ne sait toujours pas si
pascal siakam qui a eu des rapports
extrêmement bon est positif avec nick
nurse ces derniers mois va rester dans
la franchise on ne sait toujours pas
même si les raptors ont joué à toronto à
tampa bay bref du coup quand on a toutes
ces incertitudes et donc celle de
calories qui a peut-être joué ces
dernières minutes avec le maillot des
raptors
je pense qu'il ya un côté évident avec
le fait que j'ai une seule va être pris
en tout cas ça représente des besoins la
seule option que je vois vis-à-vis de
scotty barnes et si en effet il ya un
deal imminent avec pastel siakam et je
pense que mike notamment que pourra
donner son avis là dessus j'ai pas plus
de retour à titre personnel j'ai
l'impression que c'est une draft plutôt
qui se joue à partir de la place 5 parce
que je ne sais pas j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger un peu avec certains du
management tout d'abord d'orlando
lorsque ça va concerner des joueurs qui
sont pas loin de chez nous et qui sont
qui ont joué et voulue par dont
récemment du codé en dôme et john amon
anciens milwaukee qui aime bien les
longs bras capelli jonathan isaac
medical anthony récemment
je ne sais absolument pas si tu vas
faire jeff feltman est ce que vont faire
du pôle pané et john hammond
ils peuvent prendre du coup minga du
scoci barnes
ils peuvent laisser passer johnsons ils
sont capables de faire absolument tout
et n'importe quoi et donc là dessus je
pense que ça va se jouer sur toi partir
du pic st il est là il est là mike je
suis là vous me voyez cette fois on te
vois tu es beau depuis le canada ça nous
fait plaisir de bons joueurs à tous deux
deux francophones canadiens je suis à
toronto rgt et on va vous laisser un
mais je ne suis pas canadien
je suis expatrié
après c'est vrai que bente où tu t'es tu
t'es exilé dans un placard comme acte
hunting
contrairement à nous elle fait des
choses utiles pour le monde entier ou à
l'inscrire possible
mike hill vous quel état hôte tech août
à haute pression sur les raptors alors
qu'il y avait beaucoup de questions
autour de cette draft on sait que les
rapts or c'est un peu bastien on en a
parlé on sait pas trop où on va en fait
parce que il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions
si à cames kyle lowry va-t-il rester on
sait même pas si on va voir un general
manager enfin le même on ne sait pas si
on aura toujours massaï à la fin à la
fin de l'été ma question c'est est on a
dit que ça pouvait être search ça
pouvait être scotty barnes les raptors
ont aussi fait un workout avec coming a
pour vous quels sont les arguments qui
ferait que ce ne serait pas sex quels
sont les arguments en faveur de scotty
barnes quels sont les arguments en
faveur de kunhinga qui ferait que les
raptors ne prendrai pas sexe alors il ya
à l'âne qui s'étire claquer des doigts
vas-y alan allée des foules toi non je
me défoule pas mais
pour moi tu sais que c'est pas le
quatrième meilleur joueur de cette sorte
assez c et il est déjà il n'est pas inné
de général n'est pas dans le groupe des
3 d'avant on a souvent voulu un peu
groupe et cette draft c'était 5 puis
c'était 4 puis s'étaient ils sont trois
pour moi sont 3es que james ex déjà soit
promis au top 5 c'est déjà extrêmement
bien parce que c'était un joueur qui
était pas promis à cette place là dans
la saison c'est un joueur qui a vraiment
surnager à à gonzaga mais dans un
contexte qui était celui qui était moi
je pense personnellement que j'ai je
pense que scotty barnes et james
goodnight sont de meilleurs joueurs que
chase ces deux jours que je resterai
devant devant lui en fait assez
honnêtement j en sais que c'est un super
joueur de l'équipe mais je vois pas le
potentiel de stars potentielles et chez
lui le potentiel star je ne le vois pas
parce qu athlétiquement je le trouve pas
assez tranchant pour ça je le vois
vraiment plus dans le le mudéjar les
gens vont peut-être crier mais je vois
plus dans un mix entre gros l'idée au
maximum londres the ball au minium un
peu se serrer un vrai toujours deux très
bons joueurs sur les braises extérieur
passeur s'est pas encore un excellent
tireur défenseur qui met de l'intensité
était un bon passeur en transition mais
un moins bon passeur
on attaque placée en réalité si je
d'offres un joueur dans le top 5
j'aimerais qu'on attaque placée il soit
aussi excellent le jeu de gonzaga
faisait qu'il avait dépassé plus facile
à faire que d'autres en réalité ce n'est
pas l'initiateur d'attac que quelqu'un
ait quelques nigam et que peut être dû à
une grille nombre je pense que c'est un
super joueur je vais dans mon top 8 mais
je ne pense pas que c'est un joueur qui
à l'instar potentiel pour changer la
franchise de toronto bastien et après on
va te dire aurevoir bastien puisque là
il ya plein de gens qui attendent donc
donc vas-y répond à la question de mike
s'il te plaît pourquoi le assez loin
pourquoi pas ce que j'allais dire aussi
potentiel en fait c'est à dire que
scotty base en face si tu prends le
plafond max je suis complètement
halluciné par le plafond max de scotty
barzh même si on peut avoir encore des
les questions de shooter 2 est de savoir
s'il était attention et flotteurs aussi
à la mi distance genre
il ya un moment où c'est un joueur de
basket oui je vous fort tous les soirs
où il a un potentiel de dengue moi et
c'est vraiment la vie quand ce que j'ai
dis donc
j'ai l'impression je le mettrais devant
jean suns eux mais quelque part j'ai
envie de dire ce serait bien que ça
crame et de sacramento
tu vois là dessus ce serait bien que
toronto fera une vraie décision sur sa
suite est en fait qu on sache vers où on
va est-ce qu'on est sur un vrai middle
est-ce qu'on bottom est-ce qu'on
reconstruit est ce que l'on sait
vraiment quels sont les éléments qu'on
va garder parce que c'est très sympa
avant de flipper gary traîne junior et
et à ninon mi mai et boucher et
compagnie mais elle qui en fait tu sors
de cette masse et donc moi à titre
personnel si je me dis que bon bah on
est en train gentil mandatant un espèce
de plafond mais très bien avec 28 avec
la lune aux billets avec à gauche et
compagnie le garçon avec lequel j'ai
envie de plus de faire j'ai des potes se
serait pas johnsons
donc c'est pour ça que je prendrai aussi
un autre garçon à la place après je me
demande s'il se prend pas des je sais
pas quel est le plat que vous avez envie
de balancer à toronto à la gueule des
gens qui font des bêtises mais peut-être
qu'ils vont se prendre ça un management
à la guerre simone faggioli son charbon
qu'est-ce qu'on balance ben au canada
quand en espagne c'est des top teams
ah oui clairement la soutiennent ou des
pelotes bien des chefs des fèves au lard
personnellement - ce petit boys et je
pense de moins en moins la cote & shoot
the sun j'ai pas l'impression que celles
de juin pour fois qu'il est un bosquet
vraiment évoluer notre dans un contexte
qui vident extrêmement favorable à
gonzaga même lorsqu'il ya un test choc
côté côte est également l'eau si je suis
heureux et qui est de son réseau de sa
prise de décision alex et moi on avait
sept
ces discussions l'arrivée où est-ce
qu'on essayait d'avoir la vérité sur la
taille des mains de jim henson et je
suis allé en très haut lieu pour savoir
ce qu'on s'envoie que l'agent jim henson
ne foule pas pour mesure 6 mai régine et
donc c'est possible s'est passé on avait
une petite main c'est sûr ben oui
camarades
donc pour moi je suis un bon joueur d'un
excellent joueur mais je crois pas
exactement on le voit que le successeur
de cambridge poids sainement très
injuste qu'on va le jeune homme de
roissy tandis que l'on rejoint comme si
tu étais bord une sombre un joueur qui
est capable de vous voyez là les
commentaires c'est faux faux pas grosse
au prince des principes un joueur qui
sait manier le ballon du poing et de
manieurs de ballons le deuxième meneur
de ballons pour l'équipe qui est très
sympa à l'intérieur la radio qu'on peut
entourer une chute qui d'un bon prenons
des décisions équipe un joueur si qui
serait enrichi dans les grands moments
qui est capable vraiment de jouer à très
haut niveau ça prend des décisions très
très rapides pour moi ou je t'aime prier
dans une mosquée y aller j'ai pris ce
qu'a dit boys rock à toronto il a très
envie c'est vrai de vrai dans le passé
loin de vous m'aidiez le tocsin je
récupère et scotty boys et joli couple
ou en place bien sûr je suis à toi te
dire dire que tu as une seule qui peut
remplacer orlov et y meurent pendant dix
ans c'est vraiment pas les données
servant pas lui rendre service
c'est vraiment grave une question sur
les albums on parle effectivement pour
jets prendre la défense de nintendo
eagles les gars juste ça manu manu enfin
la cva chez lui il va il va arriver manu
avant cela
merci bastien merci à vous les copains
merci à vous et évidemment merci pour
l'invitation et puis je vous souhaite un
bon une bonne draft jeudi soir et
j'imagine après ça ça redémarre sur 2022
avec des gamins qui vont nous régaler
sur la saison suivante on y est déjà on
y est déjà
regardez les championnats jeunes et le
lycée tout ça donc donc effectivement
merci à toi d'être passé c'était très
très cool liasse mercier a continué bien
joue bonne draft à toi aussi
juste une question à pierre qui a
bientôt plus de batterie sur la draft
des raptors qui ont deux choix au
deuxième tour est ce que tu peux
rapidement parlé de deux prospects
européen qui pourrait glisser à cet
endroit là et qui pourrait peut-être
intéressés notre ami mike avec pedro
rousseff qui est un pivot et jocko
baptiste qui est un meneur
ouais donc je co by this on l'a vu en
euroligue avec s'aguerrissent depuis
deux ans il a eu une grosse montée de
entendre entendre juste et cette année
où il est passé
deuxième meneur deuxième arrière donc
troisième arrière de la rotation ou est
rentré il avait à peu près 21 minutes en
euroleague et avec une force une forte
augmentation en cédant sa production
offensive
c'est un meneur gauche et qui va être ce
qui va se positionner souvent dans le
dans le corner qui va être bon un peu
partout mais qui va être excellent dans
rien vraiment un qui manque un peu
d'explosivité
il va s'il a signé là au barça pour deux
ans je crois donc je le voyais bien
aller s'aguerrir avec son coach italien
au barça et revenir dans deux ans tant
que quand est la situation se sera
améliorée à toronto qu'ils auront
peut-être besoin d'un backup pour pour
un seul clou ou un autre ou un autre
effectivement et puis troussel du coup
et pour petru ça on parle de duemme pipi
de la bea league donc c'est la ligue
adriatique où on retrouve tous les tous
les pays des balkans à peu près m 10 pi
meilleur scoreur et qui était avant à
gonzaga qui a développé son shoot en
fait dans toute l'année pour devenir une
un joueur avec un shoot à trois-points
respectable et qui va être
principalement soit derrière l'arc soit
l'état de l'art arquette a enfoncé pour
finir ça c'est plus un scoreur que
qu'autre chose qui peut peut-être joué 5
4 pour élargir le jeu sur du small ball
voilà merci merci pierre et friendship
heights placé jeudi soir la draft
falloir va falloir y aller un bon gars
sait il va falloir se se renseigner sur
envergure pensé oh merci pierre ta
bientôt plus de batterie ta j'espère que
tu as encore de l'essence pour rentrer
merci pour ce passage depuis ta voiture
tu me régale plaisir et aller vers un
plus à plus fiables
mike s ata convaincus qu'elle est jamais
arrivé j'ai une autre question du coût
vas-y imaginons on va dire seul ou d'arn
c'est la même question en fait pour vous
comment vous l'insérer dans l'effectif
actuel des raptors
est-ce qu'il va dans le cinq de départ
ça me paraît compliqué après on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de d'incertitude par
rapport au fait que peut-être si à
cannes pourrait être transféré kyle
lowry ne pourrait ne pas resigner malgré
tout comment vous le voyez je me
rappelle que j'avais lu le scouting
report de ben et qu' il nous parlait il
fallait pas être étonné si parle prenait
le poste 5 dans un small ball à toronto
donc je me disais peut-être prémonition
comment vous le voyez un peu dans dans
le cinq des raptors
est-ce qu'il serait titulaire déjà les
deux ou est-ce que vous les voyez en
sortie de banc pour leur première année
allez-y les gars
je pense que si je doive seul louis tu
devrais le faire et risquerait de start
et après ce que ce qu'ils termineraient
les modes c'est pas c'est pas la même
chose il ya une différence entre doit
commencer et avec qui toujours moi je
pense qu'en réalité tant j'étais jeune
zhu ball engler donc ce que votre sexe
oral à balan pas tout le temps parce
qu'il sera pas je pense l'initiateur
principal à bordeaux vous avez d'un mec
en devant 9 lite est qui qui est un très
bon joueur d'attaqué sur des bois
extérieurs tahin hobbit a presque sa
gamme faudra voir peut-être ce qui se
fait à l'intersaison
je viens de voir la qui a une qualité
wever qui a été donnée à carry trade je
crois du côté de toronto ce qui est
assez logique en réalité mais ce que je
le vois en bas dans tomba courte qui va
qui va défendre parce que sils tech
vendre vite c'est sûrement vendent vite
tu veux pas qu'il soit en un contre un
contre le meilleur de tt le meilleur
guarda devers c'est peut-être que ce que
pourra s'occuper et je vois là peut-être
pousser la balle en transition courir
défendre et commencer à développer son
appréhension collective et son tir pour
barnes cheka avec ben et alex on a un
peu des avis différents sur comment
l'utiliser comment l'insérer moi je
pense que si tu lui donnes la balle tout
de suite en nba sans attaquer sera
moyenne alors est-ce que c'est ce que ça
te dérange parce que ça te dérange pas
est ce que tu veux gagner des matches ce
que tu veux pas gagner des matches trop
prochain plutôt de développer
scotty ben moi je pense que dans ce mot
le pôle famille peut surtout si tu es un
mec comme boucher à côté qui est super
long franchement tu peux avoir
défensivement tu peux tout switcher et
tout ça peut être super intéressant et
en tant que bad deuxième porteur de
balle c'est à dire par mec qui va
l'initier mais si tu lui donnes la base
sur une sur une passe si tu lui si tu
lui fais un décalage il va pas faire
n'importe quoi il va pour faire prendre
la bonne décision c'est un vrai team
player c'est si je pense que ça serait
super bien de l'utiliser comme ça pour
moi j'ai quand même l'impression que ça
ferait vraiment doublon avec 6 à cames
en fait parce que c'est vraiment siakam
le cégom derib hollande l'heure chez les
raptors de plus en plus et en fait c'est
là que j'ai vraiment du mal après je
suis vraiment d'accord que défensivement
une line up avec hojy avec barnes avec
siakam avec 28
défensivement c'est vraiment très solide
en plus toronto aime bien tous witch et
donc ça me paraît intéressant mais c'est
vraiment un appât et que j'avais écouté
aussi votre votre pote sur les quels
joueurs de cette grave pour être
principaux bolender justement et vous
l'avez vous aviez mis band plutôt en
secondaire et vous avez dit que ça
serait compliqué je me laissais lui qui
avait parlé du fait de faire tourner une
attaque autour de lui je pense que à
toronto
ça sera pas du tout le cas parce que ce
que j'aimerais préciser c'est que
toronto n'est pas dans je pense pas que
toronto sont en reconstruction même si
beaucoup aimeraient toronto va viser les
playoffs la saison prochaine et moi je
mettrais même une pièce sur le fait
qu'ils seront en playoffs mais voilà
c'était vraiment ça ma question je sais
pas s'ils viennent à une réponse
différente par rapport au rôle de scotty
barnes est ce que en fait ça que ça
serait pas plus la facilité en fait au
final mais peut-être que comme vous
l'avez dit y'a pas le le même le même
plafond en fait ben une réponse courte
après c'est manu qui tranche et après on
parle de new york oui moi je crois que
moi je crois qu'il va être qui va
enlever la pression à pascal fiatte
herman grosse présence physique qui a
regardé pour pouvoir s'écarter pour
shooter on va pas profiter plus du shoot
de pascal siakam je crois que toro
dossier quoi que ce soit en attaque
c'est très égalité rien c'est à dire que
plus de buzz possible mieux donc où est
2è 3è si elle parlait pour soi et aller
ils nous ont beaucoup d'habitués se sont
acheté beaucoup de bons qu'armand avec
leur fils avec le championnat et c'est
quelque chose
johnson c'est le choix le jeu mais
commence touches je te démange le
plafond manu bienvenue déjà merci
répondre à jb juste à son sondage et tim
krul est team courgettes j'ai pas vu le
sondage du gibet c'était quoi courgettes
ou quoi aubergines courgettes aubergines
il y avait deux autres deux autres
légumes courgettes il ya plus de dire
est qu'il ya plus de versatilité
un peu comme scotty barnes scotty barnes
ou jazz angels
bah moi j'ai envie de dire en fait je
m'en fous du qui a dans l'équipe prend
le meilleur talent possible et donc et
donc bah là je suis assez hésitant parce
que dans mon big board jugé sage et
scotty barnes en termes de parce que
wall comme peine odile c'est beaucoup
trop fort partout en fait foi ya un
plafond tellement haut que je me dis
c'est peut être assez incroyable et j'ai
est dans le bain mode draft sans aucune
information ni rien uniquement de mes
neurones geox parce que c'est un joueur
que j'adore et parce que parce que c'est
un passeur parce que c'est pour moi il
est l'élite passeur du livre visionnaire
en fait est très très bon défenseur ce
sur plusieurs positions donc cela sera
vraiment aux ogm d'autoroute autres
selon moi je suis j'aime je prends
scotty barn je pense j'hésite longtemps
je pense donc voir avec manu qu'est ce
que tu veux mike je suis désolé on
aurait pu parler de toronto dès 2000
heures de plus mais voilà on a fait
notre séquence
tu as eu des réponses partielles dis moi
qui tu veux toi avant de partir moi je
veux faire confiance au general manager
toronto a toujours su faire les bons
choix
on l'a vu avec hojy on l'a vu avec 6 à
camon l'a vu même avec des joueurs non
drafté donc confiance à un masaï en
espérant qu'il soit toujours là mais à
priori il se charge de la draft donc
voilà je donnerai pas de réponse je
donne je laisse ma sai faire le choix
c'est cescole l homme d'organisation
bravo mike bravo mike tu une petite plus
perso quand même pour le dino ce talk
que tu que tu animes que tu organises
qui parle de l'actualité des raptors et
puis tu bosses social express.ca
lexpress.fr pour retrouver les comptes
rendus de chaque match des raptors
auquel j'assiste et di noto qu'on a un
avant match peut être un après match la
saison prochaine on verra si on revient
dessus et régulièrement des podcasts
l'ont aussi en live tweeter avec russ
grimm un peu donc un ski qui dit qu'il
ya un échange quoi ou quoi qu'est ce
qu'il ya alors memphis en voie de jonas
valanciunas
le nude pic 17 51 points les sauts le
pic des semaines fils montrent en
décembre au hockey voilà au pays gagnent
contre l'ex madame habitants que
j'allais dire la raquette blade soul la
raquette valanciunas adams
ils sont prêts à gérer voilà ce qui va à
dame s'est blessé au pour monter en dise
et en séparant plan de chasse et du 17
et à mon avis si une belle fille spip
l'indicé qui feint non tu sais qu'ils
ont comme une idée du joueur voit les
gens qui veulent et comme ils draft
assez bien une target twitter dans la
room
il cherchait quelque hamas et puis ça va
les chevilles et et ça va aller chercher
du springer peut-être guidée 10
peut-être le monde ici le cas de thomas
messieurs messieurs on dit merci à mike
on va parler 12 je laisse la grâce
merci beaucoup mike des traces et c'est
très cool très cool a plus
waouh il ya des bombes qui tombent bien
même il ya un premier tour protéger via
les lakers de 2022 qui procédent le duo
incroyable du domaine fiscal fils et un
coup de coeur bah oui même si c'est un
coup de coeur dans le top 10 ça c'est
clair
ben qu'on pronostique sur le coup de
coeur sur le coup de coeur j'ai envie de
jaden springer qui serait absolument
incroyable à côté de djawad complément
[Musique]
même pièce like et je crois que moi je
dit ça sans johnny je suis désolé mais
ça sans johnny witter sais pas pourquoi
j'ai pas câliner maison ça peut ça peut
être très très dur
dites nous dans le dites nous dans le
chat si vous avez des pronostics pour
pour la target des des grizzlies ce
qu'ils aiment quelqu'un très très fort
ça c'est sûr et certain
après après voilà il ya du kyle jones
moi j'ai vue de trois personnes deux
recueils du hawk-eye jones pas mal quand
un effectivement quentin qui est damien
qui nous parle de kayes
ouais ouais ouais il a glissé je précise
dans la dernière moque de djibo il a
glissé il a bien glissé l'amicale qui
était vu peut-être borderline top 10 et
qui là se retrouvèrent top 20 alors il
passera pas le 20-22 du son potentiel
ben parle vite fait de kayes jones
pendant qu'on accueille julie france se
jouera que je ne sais pas trop quoi
faire avec six jeunes rats frais
nettement ses piètres case athlétique
tout autant que pourrait créer
constant je voyais un shoot d'un gars
qui coiffe pas bonne mobilité très
fluide comme athlète à moses maudit
effectivement mais il sera peut-être
partie avant on a on à julie avec nous
un peu moins de testostérone s'il vous
plaît ça fait pas de mal samedi
bon ça fans des knicks merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous est aussi créatrice de
dunkin alors est ce que fait ta promo en
20 secondes tu as vingt secondes promo
de sa part de lifesize est un peu de
culture autour du autour du basket
évidemment alors je t'ai demandé
d'arriver en tant que fan des knicks
avec une question ou une hotte tech
quelle est elle vas-y soumet compte d'un
de mes nerfs chez les knicks à la fin de
la saison
à la fin de cette saison ou à la fin de
la saison prochaine
rochelle ok allez ben ben il est fan des
knicks dont qui peut répondre s'il va y
avoir des rigoureuses avec les knicks
d'offres incroyable qui va durer dix
mois j'aurais dit que les knicks était
candidat va aller chercher de l'aide
mais d'après moi il va y avoir un meneur
slash combo guard qui va être drafté
avec 19 21 puis va y avoir un agent
croyable des dj augustine dans ce monde
il ya nous avons je crois dans les
discussions oui je enrobé
je le fais apparaître comme ça c'est
génial par magie et orchestre
directement c'est vrai mais wayne drogba
ce serait un rêve
moi je trouve que ce serait vraiment un
mix parfait avec tout le chemin d'autres
parce que l'on se parle et en plus à un
premier pas est ce que ça va se passer
je ne sais pas mais moi j'y donne 4
millions romain combien de mineurs aux
knicks
je passe te klaus michael d'entrée comme
ça tu es bien échauffés c'est un peu
c'est un peu une arlésienne ça le lemon
euronics parce que ç'a toujours été un
poste où ils ont soit eu des des mecs
vraiment fort mais ça n'a pas marché
nécessairement et que certains soient
des baisses absolues
est-ce que j'ai jamais trop le post et
new york chez une espèce de chantier
permanent c'est enfin je sais pas ce
qu'en 16 baisse parce que c'est moi je
sais la sagrada familia
ouais non mais c'est ça moi aller à
l'époque quand ils avaient la cote se
décrit shell et charlie ward je suis je
ne supportais pas le post le new yorkais
quoi tu ne peux tu me parles des knicks
mike tyson
je pense à ces joueurs là tout de suite
il faut il faut il faut quelqu'un ou
quelqu'un qui est espèce de folie ball
dans le cher new yorkais je sais pas je
sais pas julie juste c'est d'accord avec
ce qu'on dit sur les meneurs à new york
et question subsidiaire qu'est ce que tu
attends du coût de cette draft où il ya
deux choix quand même au premier tour
pour new york
battus définisse clairement les rôles
rôles en fait parce que c'est vraiment
cette franchise
fait-il bon bah front j'espère qu'il va
avoir l'opportunité de se la jouer
ailleurs quoi et qu'on perd la place à
crêches panne spécialistes que je
pourrais pas dire qu'il faudra après
tout ce que vous voulez
des nouveaux joueurs activement mais tu
attends tu attends en meneur tu attends
des joueurs prêts à aider tout de suite
où tu veux du dieu de la star tu veux
essayer de choper un mec tu risques et
continue de ne pas se brûler les ailes
tout de suite de l'année prochaine
l'argent est vraiment ça sent vraiment
continuer ce qu'on a trouvé cette année
[Musique]
vous pas tirer vraiment tout de suite de
la star et le talent brut bent est
d'accord qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu
veux plus du nba ready toi ou du talent
brut
ouais je crois qu'il faudrait juste
posco c'est la taille de cette année
déjà des joueurs qui vont avec les
joueurs on alors qu'ils contenaient mans
va pas qu'on devrait passer quelque
chose qui fonctionne de quelque chose
qui fonctionne avec un diabète avec le
chemin d'autres c'est quelque chose qui
est archi dans les playoffs c'est parce
qu'il y avait pas assez d'options
offensives
une fois qu'on utilisera donc des
joueurs qui complémentent qui sont
solidement pour répondre à la question
sur youtube les knicks ont deux 2e tour
32 58
c'est je pense un jared bateleur que
j'aime beaucoup de bonheur qui serait
capable d'être un deuxième qui est
capable de shooter aussi capable de
jouer avec ce ballon chris duarte ont
été discutées ou détruits murphy either
jackson parce que jouer à kentucky est
représentée par c'est aussi le nom
option vous pour payer nos l'un d'eux
noël on a à peu près une copie qui copie
carbone physiquement à yzeure jackson
donc où elle est juste au seul rap de
profondeur dans l'équation nous pas la
tête
allons chercher des joueurs qui essayent
mon roman tu l'as vu déjà jaser jackson
je sais que tu es en train de réviser
le bouton mieux q ha non c'est pas ça
moi je ne t'entends pas en tout cas
réseau faible je pense je vais essayer
de débrancher des trucs pour qu'on
remonte en réseau pardon à ceux qui nous
regardent
manu qu'est ce que tu penses de 19 et 21
quels sont tes meilleurs valeurs à
choper à cet endroit là bas moi je
construit autour de bach et haendel et
je trouve qu'un france wagner a bien
là-dedans un viatique des francs et qui
shoote
je trouve que ça leur va bien et c'est
un peu dans le mood tom thibodeau
il est déjà dans son rôle il a
l'expérience professionnelle l
expérience universitaire il va savoir ce
qui va ce qui va devoir faire et moi je
trouve qu'ils collent bien aux fit
knicks et il ya aussi le talent pour moi
c'est son règne la partir de 2 2
millions deuxièmes de premier tour
absolument ben c'est peut-être même un
peu un peu au bas pardon pour francine
ex-aequo nul mois il va être parti à vin
d'os mais oui moi qui en douze les spurs
l'espèce il est là ils le prennent
on ne voit pas trop membres de dos je
pense qu'ils peuvent consacrer heureux
de l'avoir poste 3-4
même si ce nom from wagner pour moi et m
le maître cette même jour j mais oui
s'ils tombent en 19 mois bon alors là on
a plein de gens qui quittent le live ça
va plus du tout julie est ce que tu as
d'autres questions on verra d'autres
attentes là pour faire une autre saison
c'est déjà pas mal
en vrai mandela déjà réglé ses champs de
céline se serait sacrément hong kong nos
bénédictions attaque fans des knicks
sont assez proches d'en avoir plus que
on ne sait pas trop bouffé d'air on va
pas trop en demander
peut-être les play off deux années de
suite a été arrêté on essaye de faire
entrer dans la fin j'ai cei
je fais de mon mieux vous nous
connaissez envergure la technique c'est
pas notre truc donc donc on essaye de
faire entrer pascal qui est qui a
longtemps vécu je pas s'il est encore un
new york romanisée 3 - est tellement de
glace
si je suis là je suis à vous m'entendez
la ti entend maintenant voilà fabuleux
feuilles la technologie c'est parfait
alors je disais tout à l'heure mais on
sait tous qui tu veux voir échouer a
échoué sur vos auteurs de draft à new
york un joueur surnommé bones pour ce
que je fais partie des gens qui
aimeraient tellement à voir là bas
ah ben oui la mère de jésus
oui oui je me sais j'aime assez jamais
c'est j'aime sm il ya plusieurs profils
par mois - et sur la sur le poste
d'arrière et contribuent le plus à
l'heure actuelle c'est duarte parce que
parce que c'est propre parce que c'est
voilà ça peut scorer dans différents
différentes situations c'était assez
proche du plafond mais met à jouer parce
que pascal qui va me faire une
apparition
extrait extraordinaire extrêmement dur
classe presqu'un fitch planning wii doit
il nous entend je crois pascal tu nous
entends je tombe bien on va vous montrer
ouais on entend aussi nickel lesquels
bonjour tout le monde bonjour tout le
monde
merci d'être là pascal appel nous ton
occupations professionnelles pour ce qui
est qui et pour quoi on a invité pour
parler de new york entre autres je
m'occupe d'un petit garçon de 2 ans le
tas principal passer d'eux
sinon anciens journaleux base allure
quoi qui a dû subir des années sans
play-offs au garden et quelques
fulgurances au sein des nets et
évidemment il a fait les chatons de
partir pour que les baisses commencent à
carburer efface devenir de la grosse
star mais voilà donc mais toujours des
attaches avec la grosse pomme toujours
toujours toujours et toujours là pour
pour taquiner le le haut me antoine
blanchard elle qui bossent pour les pour
les pour l'équipe maintenant
et voilà toujours toujours et puis avec
différents exécutifs dans différentes
équipes qui braque les joueurs nba
certains joueurs français que avec
laquelle je suis encore en contact puis
bon c'est toujours la ligue 1 on est
tous des passionnés quoi donc voilà
absolument alors pascal je sais pas si
si je te pose une question piège mais tu
m'avais dit je vais me renseigner
ouais en fait oui au niveau des insiders
sur la draft visiblement c'est busy là
au sein de la hausse indique cela et
j'ai deux personnes à qui tu veux parler
ça s'est pas fait mais heureusement
c'est pour ça que j'étais un état
j'étais un peu contre détenir détenu en
attente je me disais tiens je peux tu
arrives à les avoir au téléphone mais
c'est un fait ça c'est malheureusement
bon qu'est ce que tu penses de crise
duarte est juste parce que tu connais un
jeu encore vraiment parlé de crise
duarte et qu'il aimait bien et qui à peu
près dans le ranch des knicks qui ont le
19 et le 21 bien j'ai pas vu souvent
joué moi j'aime bien williams zahia
williams ouais c'est vrai pour être je
le sens je le sens bien pour les knicks
ça serait sympa et puis après bien
évidemment encore les déconnexions et
connexions sievh offert que jackson se
retrouver là bas aussi
peut-être qu'à jones le têt garuba waits
garuba garuba ça serait vraiment enfin
le problème c'est que sur le papier ça a
l'air génial avec thibault
dit voilà il est muet me faire jouer les
aime ce genre de joie mais comme il sait
pas jouer des jeunes c'est un peu le
seul problème
mais sinon sur le papier ça c'est
extraordinaire en tout cas il est chez
sia ou aussi oui mais mes pieds je pense
que ça serait vraiment un bon fit le
seul problème c est ce que ti blanc fin
est-ce que tu ne ferais d'accord pour
prendre déjà et puis parce qu'il le
ferait jouer parce que 50 euros qui avec
avec type c'est compliqué ah bon qui est
l affaire au clair obscur là je confirme
vous avez vous avez vous avez vous avez
fasher roman à l adema il a fait un
petit sourire
je crois que vous l'aviez fâcher un bon
c'est à dire non c'est mon côté shox ça
tu sais bagarre alors question
intéressante simplement envie tu sais
garuba plus randle romain on peut jouer
avec les deux ou pas pouvoir tout dépend
de ce que tu attends un peu
ouais tout dépend de tout dépend de ce
que tu attends de tonka traitons 5 mai
mais je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
il faut tirer un peu pressés tout tout
tout dépend de tout dépendra comment
s'est organisée mais c'est pour un
support audio dioscoride yo yo après ils
ont surtout besoin de scoring comme amon
mx ou avion pain c'était un peu tendu
quand même parcours des options on
disait bones island qui est peut-être un
d un des dix meilleurs
si on parle de scoring pur de cette
draft capable de se créer son tir
manutea d'autres options au scoring au
scoring tout court
bayonnais mais il sera plus là c'est
tellement dommage il petit peut être là
je crois que j boni l'avait pas si haut
que ça dans sa mode draft cameron
tavannes le garou bas je rende en deuil
est-ce que c'est capable est-ce que
c'est qu'avant d'être stable et de être
confirmée voilà la clé de la rrq la
question pour moi hélas email qu'il a
vraiment passé le cut effectivement
parce que bon statistiquement cette
année il s'est initié comme quelque
chose de solide il est pas loin des 6
passes par match en plus donc
effectivement il ya un truc là dessus
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas c'est pas
c'est pas ça me paraît pas déconner il
fait des choses lamentables des choses à
las vegas plus complètement julie pour
pour finir sur sur ses knicks est ce que
est ce que tu vois du lustre haendel
confirmé comme 10e romain je sais pas
j'ai un petit doute parce que je contre
allée chercher
j'espère qu'il fera pas deux siècles
après ça serait bien qu'ils restent ans
a consulté mon père de faisait soir bon
bon tu préfères tu préfères limiter les
attentes pour mieux être surprise par la
suite compris on a compris julie merci
beaucoup d'être passé en tout cas à ce
grand live à cette planète draft merci
beaucoup julie de dunkin et fran des
knicks on va continuer à parler de cette
draft et on va passer sur un sur un
petit quizz messieurs dans quelques
secondes on va on va accueillir
on va accueillir pierre migou pierre
goux mieux j'ai jamais dans quel sens ça
se dit c'est son nom il va nous faire un
petit quizz pierre de la data team
en attendant pascal je crois que je
l'avais demandé d'arriver avec une hotte
tech ou une question sur la draf des
pélicans je crois que malheureusement la
drogue saisie est terminée la gt gt
chaussures guider mais là c'était trop
dur
on rappelle aux reds on peut rappeler le
trade peut-être pour ceux qui sont dans
chatter compas du loud bande il envoie
du lourd il envoie valeurs nous pis on
voit valanciunas et le choix de draft
numéro 17 et 51,3 contre steve adams
blade soho le choix de 10 et le cas
pente et devenir encore plus chaud en
ben ouais c'est ça en fait explique
ouais ouais donc c'est assez c'est pas
étonnant c'est pas étonnant et surtout
temps c'est pas étonnant mais oui enfin
ça veut dire que comme le précise comme
l'a précisé vos pages qui sont peut-être
chose sur le robot l'ont fait dégager du
salary cap pour le garder en fait parce
que là c'est st défunt le contrat de blé
tout c'était une scène je sais plus
combien il lui devait la c'est un truc
de fou c'était n'était ce pas je suis
maintenant que je voulais je laisse
était c'était le 18 18 et 19
donc ça ça permet de dégager beaucoup
d'argent pour pour garder lobo les
petits toutous points dans cette
direction j'ai l'impression absolument
absolument
est-ce que tu as une autre question sur
la draft et après on va passer au quiz
donc il faudra que que je te dise au
revoir pascal et ce sera à grand regret
heureusement c'est ça surtout d'un droit
à toute question sur le trafic le qui va
être le donneur admin ch cette année
allez bam un nom chacun donovan michel
donc pas de rester dans le top 10 mais
l'option numéro 1 de son équipe c'est ça
que ça veut dire un de nos vins
exactement exactement
ben eager manu touche christopher romain
ringer ça me plaît pas
unia ressembler aux dépens au maillet
correia après niort ça ne plaît pas mais
j'ai moi j'ai toujours du mal à
positionner les choses comme ça mais je
préviens ce n'est pas allé hier williams
pour moi c'est emballé c'est pesé
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup pascal
d'être d'être passé on t'a vu
franchement une seconde cinq à l'image
c'est un plaisir
je pense que c'était suffisant de
pardonner de cauchemars aux gens c'est
parfait sinon celle de la lave et de la
vérité le plus le plus difficile dans la
vie c'est quoi c'est à new york ou de
s'occuper d'un petit 2 en plein temps
non mais vraiment york
vivre à new york honnêtement ccc
tranquille ça c'est tranquille c'est
tranquille mais bon le petit c'est que
du plaisir je rigole le petit c'est que
l'ipc en se marre bien avec lui on se
parle d'un merci pascal en tout cas
d'être passé tu nous a régalés et si tu
as les infos que tu devais avoir
n'hésite pas jeanvoine joue un petit
texto texto on les mettra devant
exactement sur la ligne rouge
merci pascal ou bonne fin de soirée à la
prochaine merci beaucoup
bon messieurs si les autres arrivent à
se connecter on devrait pouvoir faire un
quiz on va pouvoir dire à alan de
revenir je sais pas si nous regarde
mais il est sous une armoire on va
pouvoir dire allen de revenir parce que
là il ya un quiz sur les anecdotes sur
les prospects cette draft alors je vous
en prie rester avec nous parce que
pierre il a il a pianoté sait même pas
moi qui fais les questions moi je vais
jouer donc donc pierre il a donc romain
tu as un petit en avance parce que
normalement tu as commencé à réviser les
petites anecdotes pour la draft adeline
si je dis pas de bêtises mais moi je les
ai pas donc donc là ça va être ça va
être sportif
effectivement en attendant mais si on
n'a pas parlé de la draft de golden
state
ben est ce qu'ils vont garder leurs deux
choix
je crois que s'ils ont le choix s'ils
ont l'occasion
qu'est ce que fait signer avec l'aca
mais rama yade qui a rejoint le banc on
peut difficilement faire plus on peut
déjà surpris wiseman et le set pour
monter manu tu y crois est ce que
quelqu'un achète ça ça le truc mais je
crois toujours que je deviens cachette
au courant wiseman grand alors attends
on va changer le programme on fera le
quiz après pierre je sais pas si tu nous
regardes on va accueillir gab pardon
mais ça va ça va pour répondre à une
question sur le chat n'y a pas du tout
hôpital ya quelques jours de téléfilm à
notre connaissance personne
malheureusement et c'est dans le même
hôpital que que le prince harry le
prince william un lien cherche
désespérément mais voilà lors il désolé
peut-être qu'il ya une anecdote hôpital
mais mais on la connaît pas il est de
retour et en direct de chez maisons du
monde 1 toujours influenceurs une
mineure en mobilier absolument il est là
et gabon tu attends je sais pas si tu
m'entends depuis le cheat urant du surf
lalanne encore en lycra je sais le
bouton le bouton entendant banques
non non non je rentre pas du surf même
si aux jo je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant très tôt au tard dans la
nuit
mais non j'avais une petite laine
j'avais froid
d'accord il fait pas chaud ici on
vouloir dévoiler en plus non solaire
jour j'étais un peu excentrique quand je
dis ça m'arrive mais ça va 16 letton
vont bien que le mur c'est je vois ton
côté c'est gentil
j'en dirai un mot maman alors
pour moi c'est énorme de décoration et
ne s'allume pas se passe des choses là
alors pierre tu vas tu vas arriver juste
on accueille gab et on fait le quiz
juste après il est dans la salle
d'attenté donc je dis ça donc je fais
removing est parce qu on est limité à 6
personnes j'expliquais ceux qui nous
suivent yab cap c'est quand tu veux on
t'attend je sais que clèves à 5 heures
du matin on va parler ni roquettes
uniquement si le des chips à ses chips
ou rien et alors
c'était quoi le débat courgettes
aubergines ou quoi j'ai rien compris
ammann huit partis aussi bon manu et par
qui la bretagne va mourir et d'escaliers
d'arriver à lille déclare son
indépendance c'est classique
oui donc on peut faire le débat à la non
parler de la draft des warriors puisque
qu'est ce que tu as en dire moins je
pense pas qu'ils vont payer deux fois
papa 7 et 14 je pense pas ce qu'ils vont
essayer de bouger un des deux pics pour
des vettel pour un vétéran qui peut les
aider tout de suite tout le monde parle
de bras de débiles ou autre mais c'est
compliqué d'aller chercher un aussi fort
joueur avec juste des pics de draft donc
non je pense qu'ils vont après s'ils
restent ans en 114 y prendront je pense
par contre peut-être un joueur allemand
un bon potentiel et meilleur tout de
suite c'est un j'ai vu pas mal ça fera
plaisir à romans mais duarte a pas mal
de liens avec avec les warriors je crois
qu'ils embarquent out et qu'ils auront
été assez impressionné ils ont même
ramené pour avoir quatre comme l'a dit
la dizaine
serge harry reid et la rotation des
voyances je pense rentrer cité ans est
là du tutorat les plus vers le talent
chance ils vont peut-être voir glisser
un coming à quelqu'un comme ça plus de
risques on peut tous les pans s'ils
veulent mais il ya plus qu au milieu où
il y aura plus de risque est là il ya la
notion genou on verra à intégrer plus de
risques la notion sous désarticulé aussi
gia gros bruit et vous globalement bien
puis il ya bien un chantier
un vrai potentiel meilleures chances les
gens ça peut ça peut pour plein de
raisons ça peut je suis assez d'accord
quand ils n'arrivent pas à rentrer c'est
difficile c'est difficile non mais on va
poursuivre vite fait sur la draft des
warriors après on aura on aura aussi ok
si à aborder et houston et on va finir à
2 heures l'avantagé c'est que si tu
couvres ok si tu couvres la moitié du
premier tour donc tiens c'est tranquille
ici cipi qu'ils ont sur les soixante
jours mais je crois que je suis prêt
dont trois dans le top 10 8 g/j qu'une
crainte c'est quoi ça va commencer à
traiter en direct à la télé on avoir du
mal à
alors voilà on voit la manu il est là oh
là là quelle vie
gab gab le bouton le bouton et haut de
gamme au moins aller dernier bouton à
gauche des cinq en bas ils sont pires
que nous à poster dunk sur la technique
je vous mets toi comment voulez vous
qu'on ne se moque pas des belges à la
voilà à l'ocab aux fraudes son micro
visiblement gab test test ce chantier
que c'est la bombe
gab je veux bien faire des efforts mais
moi je veux parler des roquettes chaud
et je suis un message à roubaix c'est
toi même tu as encore msn c'est un
nouvelle appli de gabat part à mon égard
vous montre où peu à la purée n'hésitez
pas sur moult c'est super chaud mais bon
comme tu as dit poster dunk
on est plus que vous vas-y gabon on est
là pour parler des roquettes 100%
et puis la belgique parle-nous des
fusées bat déjà en toute transparence
j'ai rien suivi par rapport aux
prospects du cauchemar est bon comme il
nous faut nous faut une question noire
et moi j'ai des hôtes et que j'ai des
questions j'ai tout ce qu'une vas-y
vas-y vas-y envoie on voit la hauteur et
vous pouvez réagir par rapport à ça
c'est personnellement je traînerais
lepic par exemple idéalement avec tour
en tour pour me débarrasser john wall et
pour récupérer leur pic alors tu te
perds un joueur style frais de 22,8
lattes évident
évidemment tu trade le pic de toi ouais
je suis pas si convaincu par john green
bien que je viens juste de dire que j'ai
pas suivi les prospects mais de ce que
j'ai vu pour moi ça a l'air d'être une
version améliorée de lou williams plus
athlétiques mais alan bien d'accord
comment je me doute je vois je vois mes
voyages et mais pour moi ça aurait plus
de valeur de me débarrasser de janeiro
que de combiner john green avec john
wall en fait le truc c'est que donc
c'était dans le top 3 quoi est ce que tu
en es ce que tu penses à john roll
compter d'octobre 3 à galérer toute la
saison c'est pas pour avoir
l'opportunité de se défaire de john hall
je pense non personnellement je ne pense
jamais john wall mais près c'est autre
chose mais en en trio mais leur logique
et pas vraiment logique vu qu'ils se
sont débarrassés de l'ardenne pour
évidemment beaucoup de pick up asturies
ils ont quand même beaucoup de chance
qui s'est blessé parce qu'il aurait été
beaucoup plus laids pour eux si ça
n'avait pas été le cas mais c'est plus
les fuites en fait je vois pas ok il ya
le talent mais est-ce que ça fitte
est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça apporte
ça va être en gros le projet c'est
d'avoir deux trois années encore en mode
temps king mais honnêtement j'ai
personnellement je serais plus de faire
un gros move de prendre un risque
prendre un joueur solide
quitte à aller deux pics plus bas et
prendra barnes par exemple je sais que
vous en avez parlé qu'il a beaucoup de
potentiel pour moi ça serait plus de
sens et plus de logique vu le roster
actuelle est ce que c'est la chose comme
beaucoup était fait à part le don de
titres ayant non mais après il faut être
créatif
justement on encore une fois est-ce que
quel est le projet de 12 tonnes
actuellement est ce que faire une paire
déjà déjà maintenant ils veulent très
des rings rigueur donne visiblement pour
faire la place donc clairement ils sont
l'opt-in de ce que j'ai entendu sur john
green
mais qu'est ce que ça apporte quelle est
la vision de court moyen terme
concrètement les scandales ans déjà
alors est ce qui est un stratège déjà
mais non c'est marrant parce que ils ont
fait des bons coups genre aller chercher
du côté de ça montre qu'ils ont quand
même un bon scouting faire le trade pour
porter en juniors c'est parfait et
derrière ils font des trucs
catastrophique comme plutôt le traite de
capella mène 13 darden aussi pour moi
c'est vraiment ça mon vraiment une
équipe en panique honnêtement
honnêtement c'est tu peux pas avoir si
peu pour un joueur qui aime bibi et qui
apporte ton équipe tu nous l'as l'info
et de la forge et elle vaut ce qu'elle
vaut mais je sais que les requêtes sont
regardés et on passait aussi au work out
of c'est énormément de joueurs passés en
europe auxquelles ils avaient des
intérêts pour pas le jour en europe et
dont ces gens ils ont ils ont ils ont
misé ont mis quelques mètres en tirant
sur un minimum de six plus grands mais
voilà les quelques quelques joueurs qui
sont passés là bas donc est ce qu'ils
regardent aussi pour des joueurs de
complément pour aller chercher un peu de
ils ont deux autres choix au premier
tour 23 24 hymne son nom après après je
pense que c'est ça se traite ça peut
traîner les pics aussi ou ou c'est pas
incohérent si l'on pique 3 et qui veut
aller chercher chercher quelque chose
d'autre moi je pense que ton but ce
n'est pas de gagner des matches j'en ai
trop prochaine non je dis que je te dis
je peux développer
tu as joué des finales de kung fu
attentes et or est dans une bille
maintenant soit tu tentes soit tu tant
qu en réalité c'était dans l'entre-deux
malheureusement qui sera pas assez fort
sentent mettre en péril dans ton futur
pour je pense qu'en réalité je ne peux
pas ne pas apprécier peut-être le fils
de john green seulement à deux dans la
draft moi je me dis toujours voix sur sa
façon de jouer un rôle si c'est pas ton
présence et c'est pas ton passé c'est
ton futur messi il n'est pas dans le
projet john wall et tout contrat est
ingérable regarde mon équipe elle a
réussi à se débarrasser de kemba walker
ce que je pensais impossible vu le coup
vu son contrat et plus ses genoux mais
je pense que tu te rases des joueurs de
talent suit les essais y est ton but
c'est je pense de retourner en clair
vous dans 2 3 ans je pense sérieusement
qu'avec jug band vite
à la place c'est tout ça tu vas même pas
ample enfin à l'ouest c'est trop dur
non mais je parle pas de play off mais
j'parle pilsen d'un projet cohérent soit
parce que le but aussi c'est que tu es
des joueurs qu'ils soient bien couvé par
exemple etc avec les kings ou les knicks
par le passé c'est beau de prendre du
talent mais si tu as une structure qui
est catastrophique ça mène même à rien
donc voilà après moi j'entends j'entends
je veux bien pourquoi pas mais même là
je dirais qu'il ya aucune garantie mais
on va dire que vous êtes les experts
pour vous john green c'est quoi le som
ceiling le potentiel maximum c'est jorge
amaral alors manu vas-y manu pour voir
une sorte de desmaures des roses année
moins fort ils sont super beau mais il a
encore beaucoup trop de lacunes de shoot
de gestion de jeu
de défense saab ont pas de meubles non
non c'est pas ça mais une troupe mêmes
joueurs il est impressionnant à voir il
est spectaculaire mais jamais trop aimé
le joueur en lui même je pense qu'il a
quand même du potentiel on y lit
notamment au tir on l'a vu aux flots
fiba où il avait montré de très belles
choses plus quand il coule non je n'ai
pas peur du tir j'ai peur d'autres
choses est-ce que défensivement ça va
réussir à tenir la route
est ce que on a parlé dans le podcast
bollingers est ce qu'il sera capable de
d'avoir cette position-là soit pris de
soin numéro une soit numéro 2 moi j'ai
des doutes parce qu'il n'a pas le temps
de le suffisant encore pour moi mais moi
je le prends je le prends pas trop moi
je fuis 2 comme houston je vais sur
mobile parce que tu es tu as
possiblement un pivot comme dire à
l'asnl et générationnelle moi je trouve
ça intéressant le vase divisé par deux
si les dons ponctuels football
environnement il ya moyen qui qu'ils
soient assez incroyable parce qu'il est
à ce moment moyens en tout il peut être
extraordinaire vraiment dans deux trois
choses et ça peut vraiment rien que ça
le rendre impressionnant est inarrêtable
moi je trouve ça très intéressant je
voulais tu soumettre sa romain entre
green et moblie je trouve que si tu veux
donner de la valeur à tes autres joueurs
puisque c'est aussi ça aide gmc allait
prendre un joueur qui va je trouve que
moblin est un joueur qui va forcément
mettre en valeur des john wall des kevin
porter même des jeans tate custom il
faut pas l'oublier c'est un des seuls
bon move qu'ils ont peur chez sia nous
aider aussi séparé ce que pour vous il
est complémentaire avec rythme le truc
c'est là là on parle pas d'un pic 12 au
mapic shell la paix implique trois qui
est quand même donc encore un peu en
tête de gondole
le vieux de deux ans ruth 1,2 par an
autant pour moi sur un pic deux je sais
pas si tu peux te permettre d'aller
faire un pareil et enfin encore une fois
je suis pas gm j'ai assez de problèmes
comme ça mais si tu si tu dérapes tissu
draft sur un sur un deuxième pic
si tu vas pas cherché le meilleur joueur
possible c'est compliqué enfin moi je
vais encore une fois je veux pas remuer
le couteau dans la plaie mais je vois
luca dans de chedjou et ce matin
quatrième pour l'instant l'histoire y
aura raison 3 elle par l'envoyer dans ce
lieu isolé
j'apprends que je comprends pas surtout
soir c'était canada avoir marre et
l'entente week end dans tous les cas
dont le futur propre à l'histoire mais
ça devait passer plus haut là pour moi
me blay ce qui me le truc sur ce que
j'ai noté sur lui les gelées sous les
yeux sur mobile est supposé schiller et
bonnes cases moi le seul le seul bémol
que je mets c'est ce qu'on avait mis un
petit peu sur le sur le site assure sur
sa fiche et la durabilité avec le profil
physique il a après il peut au contraire
il peut prendre des rebonds il ya déjà
des choses qui fait très bien ont ils
tous de 12 double double en patois de
cette saison c'est quand même plutôt
bien
après derrière ses montées très fin il
ya le talus pour le contre il ya une
capacité à avoir de la pac défensif
d'après notre côté ça ma gauche ces
rendez vous en terre inconnue donc il ya
plein de choses aussi qu'ici il ya des
choses mais je suis là il a un profil qu
est l autoroute à leurs hôtes à lens il
est dispo je pense que c'est pas des
collants parce que toute façon lui dans
2 3 ans vous avez vous avez non draft
pas forcément le cas dans il soir de
fuite importante aussi est ce que tu
peux avoir un talent qui peut très bien
se gaufrer aussi si le l'environnement
est pas bon c'est juste pour répondre à
ce vilain sur hamouma et qu'est ce qui
est ce qu est ce qui est peut-être vrai
dans le fond mais à un moment tu tu dois
faire des choix mais là là pour le cas
du pour le cas du 2 le profil de mobley
toute façon avec les joueurs qu'il a eue
derrière vous et vu robben sur la sur le
sur la coupe du monde 19 d'allouer
maniema car il avoue avoir des profils
comme ça si ces profils qui arrive de
vienne deviennent dominant ou de
vieilles quelque part le
un petit peu la norme à rechercher ces
jours là vont être prioritaire et on en
a déjà parlé
les franchises de fond que recréer le
modèle de satisfaits qui fonctionne si
aujourd'hui on n'avait que des postes 5
à à à 2 15 hae à 125 kg tout le monde
cherchera des cinq ados qu'un les 125 kg
et on reformeraient à nouveau des
joueurs sur ce profil là en ce moment on
est dans du positionne être basque bon
on fait des trucs comme vous je vous
fais des trucs qui vont dans ce sens là
à un moment moi c'est ces points communs
cohérent pardon d'aller chercher le
bella ou parce que chantal ans il
correspond à l'archétype même
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on va demander un
grand courir mettre la balle au sol
défend de faire un petit peu tous là lui
par contre c'est qui fait beaucoup de
choses correctement
je ne vois rien faire excellemment bien
si ce n'est peut-être contré à la limite
mais est-ce que c'est suffisant sachant
qu'il est un petit peu encore un petit
peu soft même si c'est des choses qui
peuvent avancer
je parle beaucoup désolé il ya des
questions sur son caractère unique qui
nous disait soft et noah qui nous dit ça
manque de nasty et il est et encore une
fois c'est le le problème le problème et
on se posera la question l'an prochain
et dans deux ans avec les joueurs dont
j'ai parlé juste avant vous avez un
joueur de grande taille comme ça qu'a de
la mobilité qui est capable de faire des
choses et qu'il ya des cas qui est caduc
a du talent cas les fondamentaux est-ce
que vous développez près du cercle
si vous le faites vous l'empêché d'être
au périmètre dont quelque part de
s'exprimer dans les anses qui peut avoir
et dans la motricité qui peut avoir
al'inverse vous le développer au
périmètre ben si vous développez
beaucoup plus au périmètre que près du
cercle
il évita blement il va jouer sur les ans
donc il y aura moins sur le contact et
la difficulté c'est que ces joueurs sont
tellement exceptionnel de par leur
profil que je pense que dans les faits
personne ne sait comment les développer
parce que ce que tu vas donner un côté
tu va l'enlever de l'autre et
inversement les impôts tu payes
entreprendre de côté c'est pareil donc
c'est s'est trouvé le bon équilibre oui
il est soft c'est sûr mais un joueur
soft est capable de mettre 2 contres et
demi par match je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui achètent quand même malgré tout
rien d'autre à dire que paris glisse
pour finir soit le mec le plus dur du
monde et pourtant je pense que malgré
tous les acteurs du sport
ouais mais voilà malgré tous les à-côtés
sportif qui peut y avoir et les
questions de pouvoir sur lui
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la moitié des
franchises de près de 4
à une baston à kaunas à riga temps à
regarder la méche pas d'accord que
mobilis nécessairement sorte oui oui
cette façon qu'ils mais on parle d'un
joueur qui a franchi des étapes
c'est une capacité à passer au travers
de la saison qui ont pris l'adversité il
y avait quelque chose avec ce parti d'où
aussi la structure qui est super
important dieuze tonnes actuellement
honnêtement c'est c'est pas solide
khwaja sur quoi tu construisent qui qui
va être le qui va le prendre sous son
aile
alors là c'est donc en gros que t'as pas
confiance en ta structure tu préfère ne
pas drafté de gros talents et aller
chercher des joueurs plus sûres en gros
ça se sent exactement et le met les
cannes alors pas risquer à la draft on
peut parler de talent m'étais jamais sur
concrètement comment on n'est jamais sûr
mais pas prendre des vieux joueurs non
plus je connais vraiment des super
joueurs et des gars qui ont prouvé même
potentiellement allez je pense qu'il ya
des gens qui seraient capables de lâcher
un
un presque le staff un deuxième pic
assez largement donc belle benaben et
après romain ça veut dire la question
subsidiaire pour toi dans le haut de la
draft
on va enlever caïds qui va à la d3 qui
est le plus sûr c'est ça la question
fait que post gain de plus de choses le
plus sonore sera clos deux parties ont
parlé de la question de savoir qu'à
cueillir sans moi j'aime beaucoup la
comparaison est là que la vie est plus
petit et restaurants de la difficulté
majeure mais où tout est à froid comme
houston jeudi
autant se ramasser une condition de
caisse qui va donner
tandis que mme aubry va avoir besoin
d'un contexte le carreau si je vous
demande quelle serait la meilleure
équipe pour lui et quelques et lequel et
qui voudraient la merde c'est trop lourd
pour jane green
je prends cela dit bon je décrypte yves
est un joueur de talent lance pas les
spurs
ça c'est cliché ça mais très cliché le
matériel mais non mais c'est pas vrai et
les équipes qui développent bien
meilleur joueur que les spurs toronto
regardez un peu depuis quelques années
mais non il ajouté je te dis houston
parce qu'il a parce qu'il a rien à jouer
là bas et c'est très bien la jouer sur
les trois quatre premières années donc
et au pire tu vas le trade et sa valeur
sera haute parce qu'il aura mis un point
par match pendant trois jeux sera par
ailleurs romain tu avais quelque chose à
dire
non j'ai vu j'ai vu plein de trucs passé
dans les commentaires là il y avait un
commentaire sur fait que port d'une
liste pour aller pas de rebond mais
c'était lien avec ce que je disais tout
à l'heure
fort de ce gars a dû aux normales il ya
plein de commentaires qui sont pas
forcément inintéressant là sur le côté
d'ailleurs c'est bien c'est bon ça va
trop vite donc on n'a pas le temps de
bâton de forcément répondre à tous mais
voilà donc c'était juste pour agir par
apprendre ça parce que je les ai vus
passer tout à l'heure moi aujourd'hui
mobley mobley le côté soft pour moi il
est un petit peu des deux côtés du
terrain c'est lié à sa morphologie
c'est lié au fait qu'il soit très
longiligne et très fin mon attaque
j'aimerais le voir mettre un petit peu
plus les pôles parce que parfois il faut
il faut pas il faut pas hésiter à y
aller légèrement plus mais après
derrière je préfère aussi avoir un
joueur un joueur intelligent et si pour
moi forcément ses appuis en défense qui
peut et il peut faire des choses comme
ça c'est encore à construire
oui oui moi je à la sig là je le veux
bien c'est tout à fait je suis d'accord
avec toi mark weiten à la cigale et je
prends un coup d'envoi les joueurs de
mai là où j'en ai eu un excès dans sa
légende et lui a par le passé
un poste là également les joueurs de
bellor j'achète j'achète tous les jours
les jours de plus s'est vendu gab
mon gable seul objectif bah je veux je
veux savoir
après tout ce que tu as entendu est-ce
que tu prends ton choix si oui green ou
mobley et sinon qu'est ce que tu fais
moi je reste sur ma position de très
bons jeux j'entends le après si je dois
absolument choisir j'ai pensé que
j'allais me brunel plus talentueux tu
prends deux fils le plus talentueux mois
gérer sur un trade en sachant aussi que
j'ai plein de pique dans le futur même
énormément c'est vraiment énormément
donc voilà je serais plutôt partie sur
un trade personnellement un petit
traître après j'avais j'avais juste une
ou deux questions pour vous alors une
histoire géographie de là mais combien
de points 5 points pour alain groisne
non mais voilà parce que à l'échec draf
je vous rencontre l'année passée à 2 ans
s'écarte johnson où tout le monde était
scandalisé qu'il était prêt si au final
mans finalement il avait que sixième à
mareth au final est ce que l'on aurait
dit qu'à un fil enfin c'est un genre il
aurait tout de même deuxième tour c'est
douteux fin bref mais quel est votre
votre joueur vous étiez sûrs et keith
finalement c'est un buste vous étiez un
peu choqué que c'était un buste et
al'inverse le joueur qui vous a surpris
aussi genre que certaines n'ont en
général dans grave plus ou moins
récentes ne vous pouvez note une belle
réussite et la droite et voilà exact
mois triangle de l'avoir en deux le
moment de sa mort j'étais un des cgt les
prix des taux les aimons le groupe est
sur la brock au oui/non marché l'arc
quoi qu'il arrive ça peut pas être que
les kings d'avoir eu moments bas devant
helton et orange
ah oui ah oui ça pitch a donc jahren
jackson commence à se transformer en
basse tout si je lui souhaite parce que
je l'avais dans l'après ok le bon
mais la juste une grosse blessure quand
il joue il joue bien donc ouais bien sûr
non mais je suis toujours derrière lui
moi j'étais fan de john grant sais pas
si les gens s'en rappellent les knicks
chicago six jeux plus l'audience il
vient de signer en italie là ça y est
j'ai rien grand et loin de chez moi je
n'ai vu manuel romain une petite réponse
vas-y manu bah moi mon plus grosse
faillite france est pas vraiment une
encore who is it mais qu'elle est une mc
daniels est ma plus grosse déception
ça remonte à loin c'est james young
l'acteur a fait quoi 13 les celtics 14
non il est pas notre juste derrière
l'autre et que moi j'adorais à kentucky
et que finalement il affirme ce taux qui
commence à rentrer dans l'eau qui est un
joueur avec a fini à l'hapoel holon j'ai
vu la dernière fois
moi je vis avec ma mère et moi je
l'avais créés au premier
je croyais dur comme fer que j'ai un
problème est que les joies d'arizona
state pis je voyais pas leur visage est
masqué jim jordan est devenu je le
voyais bon après ça explose aussi plus
que tu peux imaginer qu'à moment par
exemple via nice tu peux pas le voir
venir
j avais j'avais jouera les départs de
chu
ok romain pour finir sur une charge sur
les sur les gadins moi je vais aller un
peu plus loin à moins sûr sur les gadins
vraiment historique toujours pas tiré
sur marca le feu de structure ces
joueurs là c'est trop facile
sam bowie ou deux jours donne s'était
lui c'était un seul mot idée là non
alors si celle ci c'est dans mes choix
moi moi très sincèrement je ne creuse
pas autant que mes collègues en classant
les choses et 11 ans big bird moque et
caetera et c'est parce que mon jeu je
n'ai malheureusement pas là là là
ressources mentales pour le faire moi je
me contente d'observer un petit peu les
joueurs sur le plan individuel sur ce
qu'ils peuvent proposer ex car etc
après derrière moi j'ai aussi si tu me
parles de devrait il ya d'un historique
je pense que je ne sais plus qui l'avait
drafté je vais rappeler immédiatement et
je pense que achille thabeet est très
très très très peace deuxième position
et d'énergie pour moi c'est sûr moins d
1 des pires bost ça et nos amis de
détroit qui avait été chercher ce ce
légendaire joueur serbe qui a quand même
fini
d'harcourt sni champion the bar
community shield voilà c'est honteux les
bennett cette rente annuelle
c'est pas mal aussi effectivement
d'allier d'aider des joueurs comme ça il
y en a mais mais c'est toujours pareil
la question c'est est-ce que c'est le
joueur qui se plante ou est ce que c'est
les gens qu'ils évaluent mal moi c'est
toujours la question pour moi et je jeu
sans doute combinaison des deux ouais
moi j'ai tendance à croire je pense à
canton de gauche sur un joueur on est
d'abord nous évaluateurs responsable de
la gamelle puisque le joueur lui-même
parce que il ya des choses qu'on a pas
du voir correctement
après il ya des gens qui passent pas le
cap il ya des gens qui se mettent qui se
met la tête dans le plafond tout seul
aussi mais globalement l'évaluateur et
plus fautif que l'évaluer d'une gamelle
mais évidemment comme ça monte en sauce
est con on se cache tout joueur
cinquante mille raisons c'est c'est plus
facile de dire moi moi dans dourdan dans
me dit que je fais aujourd'hui je me
cacherais jamais voilà on construira
lourdes groupe sur un joueur parce que
mais c'est nous qui avons mal évaluer sa
capacité à faire les choses à sa
capacité à vivre dans une équipe avait
dans
bravo simplement gérer la pression ce
cas - autres ce qu a draftés on dit
souvent c'est gagner au loto
sauf que l'une équipe va d'essayer de te
faire gagner au loto si l'équipe fait
l'erreur elle t'a fait gagner au loto
mais toi tu y es pour rien d'un autre
côté on vient de choisir le conte c'est
celui qui achète ou suty vent c'est
toujours pareil on voit que je pense
qu'il faut aussi quelque part la la la
la remise en question il ya tout tunis
de all star d' de gadins et qui passe
maintenant dans les commentaires
mais voilà c'est savoir se remettre en
question et surtout je voudrais aussi on
s'est tous go fritsch et lire des choses
moi j'ai regardé les joueurs récemment
tu vois le podcast qu'on a fait le trou
avec avec rami un petit podcast vidéo
j'aime beaucoup charles cooper regarder
jouer j'ai creusé j'aurais certainement
pas michael johnson à sa place parce que
j'ai du mal avec johnson mais charaï
cooper je suis fait avoir par là il peut
étudier quelque chose tu creuses un
petit peu tu dis c'est survendu
là dessus je m'offre par exemple mais
parce que parce qu'il ya un moment où tu
t'accroches un poids live il ya des
choses qui pèse 7 joueurs mais bon voilà
pourquoi nous c'est pas notre métier on
fait ça aussi on fait ça avant tout pour
le plaisir
en tout cas merci pour vos réponses les
gars je pars je vais pas rester plus
longtemps je pense que j'ai déjà les
trains qui l'ont parfait bah écoute
parfait je vais vous écouter avec
plaisir et c'est que vous avez un peu
taquiné mais voilà même si garde d'être
passé est de la team poster dunk
évidemment donc c'est la famille grand
plaisir et merci d'être passé d'avoir
patienté aussi tard alors que tu
travailles de bonheur non un peu plus
tôt me force et s'il faut faire des
sacrifices pour la c1 pays gabaye
vraiment bravo merci merci romain comme
d'habitude
ciao les gars et on va on va te draft et
un belge femmes et hommes
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils croient pas non
enfin je serais étonné mais ça serait
cool en tout cas moi je vois lille
devant dahlan
il ya un trader qui demande si voilà il
enlève ton snap pour sa soeur sites
appelés quelque chose c'est incroyable
ce qui est en train de s'effacer moi je
lui devais bien ça fait trois fois
qu'ils demandent en plus wallabies au
gab bisous je te décroche non bah on
donne on donnera les snap en temps voulu
wen au match aller nous donneront les
sna pourtant voulez ou alors si cette
personne répond bien une question
pourquoi pas
mettons le stade on joue hélas la foire
aux célibataires remettre en vente
et sinon tu peux le trouver dans un fop
probablement dans un monsieur meuble
quelques planches ils tiennent
exactement
oui c'était inattendu après j'ai trouvé
ça trop beau et je trouve toujours se
trouve wager vécu un vécu que racial une
très très longue de direct en télévision
où on s'est tous regardé quand on a vu
son nom sortir on s'est tous regardés
l'art de dire qu'il connaît et qui peut
en parler et j'ai regardé sur les notes
que j'avais qu'on avait prises tout au
long de la saison qui plus est sans des
mois je le voyais c'est une vraie
surprise
mais bon il est 6ème homme certes ce
n'est pas non plus voilà il joue pas non
plus en en deuxième division albanaise
un repas et à ceux qui nous écoutent
il y en aura cette année encore des
surprises ian williams est revenue mais
les hommes ayant n'aura cette année il
va y avoir des noms fin de premier tour
improbable là nous et quand je vais dire
ça il va paraître chez first team on va
s'arrêter probablement à la loterie donc
donc on n'aura peut-être pas trop de
surprises mais romain chez bwin vous
allez avoir grosse surprise des gros
gadin fin de premier tour sa batterie
comme ça ça va être fabuleux c'est
fabuleux
on a hâte tom trager ça va je vous
écoute du put alors je me régale
ti maillot du psg un maillot du psg dont
j'étais torse nu il ya exactement 14
secondes j'ai cru comprendre qu'elle a à
calais m'avait beaucoup de succès et ça
a commencé depuis quelques mois sa faute
c'est ta faute
thomas doublé chaussure à son pied
maintenant alors c'est sûr car elle fait
du 36 donc soyez bien précises
si vous voulez envoyer des nude voilà
comment on est bien qu'on a commencé
bien fort entre castres et couleurs nous
avoir simplement temps bah oui ça fait
longtemps tu veux nous est venue pour
parler que plaisir que les coeurs je
faisais après les calmes depuis tout à
l'heure vous parler de deux au choix de
draft
bon ok mais coeur sur moi c'est un peu
plus bas c'est intéressant
il y en a du fan des lakers c'est clair
ça c'est clair donc du coup je n'ai été
que question parce que assis en vrai
malheureusement cette année l'année un
peu compliqué pour le chevelu prospects
heureusement que vous êtes là tous pour
pouvoir nous raconter un peu ce qui se
passe qui on va voir les prochaines
pièces mais du coup en fin de premier
tour
franchement je suis un peu comment
dirais-je un peu à l'ouest sur les sur
les prospects donc donc j'ai besoin de
votre aide et la première question que
je me pose pour les petits lakers c'est
pas qui est drafté c'est ce que les
lakers ont vraiment besoin de racheter
et est ce que les lakers sont vraiment
sympas à pelinka il n'a pas il a un peu
l'habitude d'utiliser la draft pour pour
alléger son portefeuille non stop
alors les avis mamane us que les lakers
doivent drafté ou pas c'est une question
un peu difficile mais mais vas-y que je
te balance bas ils ont un choix autant y
aller moi aussi j'ai vu je suis pas
spécialiste nba je regarde que d'un oeil
je pense qu'ils ont enfin je pense je
trouve qu'ils auraient besoin d'un
meneur je sais pas s'il compte
contredira parce qu'il ya le brand donc
c'est un peu compliqué mais j'irai plus
si si lady s'ils sont disposés vienne
mitchell ou un trait man david mitchell
ou très mal c'est pas mal c'est des gens
les prospects qui glisse surtout david
mitchell qui était un temps vu vers le
top 10 et puis petit à petit on se dit
bon en fait il a quand même il va avoir
22 ans il a déjà vingt deux ans je sais
plus quoi il va avoir 23 ans exactement
donc ce qui n'est pas forcément ce qu'il
veut pas dire qu'il va échouer mais ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya moins de
potentiel que d'autres plutôt un arrière
tom qu'est ce t'en penses de la première
proposition de manu c'est ça paraît
logique où est ce que toi tu irais est
ce que toi tu devras ferait un talent à
développer sur plusieurs années un peu à
la denver ce qu'ils ont fait ces
dernières années tu vois après c'est
vraiment le l'occasion ou t'es acheté
sûr mais c'est vrai que je suis partagé
aujourd'hui on a un peu de mal à savoir
ce que l'on ferait des coeurs s'il ya
tellement de chantier que je sais pas si
les lakers hurle envie d'aller chercher
un jeune joueur talentueux
je vis du très mal très mal sa très
bonne qui apparaît souvent aussi et
pourquoi pas un arrière scoreur
effectivement en arrière meneur combos à
lons direct mais ce type de profil là
j'ai la sensation qu'il faut avoir
beaucoup de chance pour tomber sur un
gars qui peut avoir de l'impact en terme
de choix ça c'est pas forcément faux
mais ben y'a quand même des joueurs qui
peut être vont donner plus d'assurance
aussi à ce niveau là de la draft que
entre 7 et 15 c'est un peu la zone de
grand danger si tu veux ouais mais avec
une équipe comme les lakers qui veulent
compétitionner qui veulent avoir
championnat et qui sont pris avec des
histoires à la moi si je suis un peu
l'école où je change de pic pour alléger
la blague cette semaine c'est que
pennequin et 7 passes et calculs mois et
qui s'épient après importe qu'il ait vu
dans la ligue mais personne ou absorber
leurs contreurs moi si je suis
wellington je me jette sur deviennent
matures
je me jette sur lui on en parle de lui
comme étant son côté parce qu'il petit
mais on parle d'un joueur qui est allé
face à face avec quelqu'un et gamme qui
réussit à le garder en respect puis je
faisais aussi capable de garder qui
étonne également respect pendant un
match également de garder à peu près
n'importe qui et leur respect liouize
tiwi va se faire shooter part de celui
mais également physique qui est
allemande tonique défensivement qu'il
capable de jouer dès la première
question sur le chandail il est
compétitif c'est ça romain aussi ce
qu'on peu éméché deviennent mitchell
pour continuer là-dessus c'est que c'est
que quelqu'un est une histoire de
l'attitude quoi ces mélanges cbcb lors
globalement ou pour moi j'ai julie j'ai
appris ça auprès d'eux joueurs que j'ai
pu côtoyer sur deux saisons différentes
on dit que certaines écoles sont
capables de façonner des joueurs mais de
manière complète la forêt compris sur la
personnalité parce que quelque part est
déjà un travail de scouting qui se fait
sur les profils qui veulent intégrer à
leur école y compris sur le cheval
dimension psychologique un mec de beer
g&g plus dans la tête des exemples de
réussite à niveau professionnel nba ou
europe ce que dès que des gamelles
terrible on l'a eu inévitablement puis
parlons perry jones
voyez par exemple la tall ships au méga
buzz mega bass il nous met à mes romans
il ressemble plus quelques années c'est
ça sort que du roleplay bébé lors c'est
que c'est simple comme villanova c'est à
dire que tu vas récupérer des mecs qui
seront pas forcément le star mais tu vas
récupérer que des joueurs ont des
habitudes de travail et d'une façon de
faire face tu nous est suivi un peu
thomas cette année sur la sur la bcl
avec le super bowl aux effets sur tweets
chat avec à roanne à un moment tu as un
mec un commis chez commisssion like le
mec mon a longtemps parlé pendant la
saison cc cc culturel ce qu'ils font
c'est culturel dans leur attitude dans
leur façon de jouer un mec de b lors je
prends tous les jours
il sait qu il peut aider pour se
structurer effectivement ça me laisse un
peu aller gerald un petit peu tous ces
dernières semaines tu vois jouer bellor
tu vois qu'il ya des règles
en attaque comme en défense tutu on
gérera pas on peut encore tirer je suis
en ambulance kentucky mais voilà ces cas
là on va dire que c'est correct
après c'est plus facile quand à 4
joueurs sur cinq qui qui shoote à 40% à
3 points que cantona 0 ouais bon quant à
l'aspect singh pour et quant à l'équipe
qui a semblé pourrait quoi que tu as des
fois quand tu bosses mais mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il y avait lors torah
plus facilement des role player ou d où
des joueurs quand vous êtes un plafond
moins élevés mais plus efficace que des
armées comme comme quelques petits ou
house finalement tut tut empilés non et
puis tu les fais jouer tant bien que mal
dans dans dans la club fn cher à chaab
aide à la toilette douche et toilettes
bouchées doit être bouché mais c'est
quelque part c'est ça ben bella bellow
chine tous les ans mais oui c'est ça
mais l'or était en ruine est en ruine ya
dix ans que dit ce que dit mon
commentaire il ya eu des histoires
terribles avant que le coach actuel
reprennent à l'europe à la boutique je
vous ai donné ces deux cd terrible ce
qui s'y passait et là aujourd'hui ben
voilà c'est un poids en prêchant alan
pour répondre à la question tome sur
est-ce qu'ils doivent draft et les
lakers en fait non or pour aller
chercher en vétérans je pense ou un
joueur qui peut tenais tout de suite
l'année dernière les clippers était
rentré ça pour luc hennart d' l'idée
était bonne la réalisation est peut-être
un peu trop baisse quoique luc hennart
de la mine épanouie en play-offs 1 mais
moi je pense que oui tu dois qui doivent
servir de ce choix là pour pouvoir
chercher un - joueurs vétérans comme
j'en avais parlé lectorat pointe deux
fois les legends clash fraudeurs mais
l'idée du rôdeur a été bonne en fait de
se rajouter un joueur de ce talent là
c'est ça ce fait compte donc contre ce
qu'ils avaient donné enfin premier danny
green tu le fais et plus de sens ils
font pas ils vont tracter un mec de
clutch
et comme j'ai regardé la liste des mecs
de clutch c'est pas je pense pas que ça
ait des meilleurs pour aider tout de
suite je ne propose quoi homonyme bat
aby et boston budget boston il peut pas
t'aider tout de suite je pense mais en
vrai mais bio boston si tu veux garder
de clients potentiels tu prends en 21
tasses quotidiennes oui ce cher à manu
taka coach ils ont aussi jéricho sims
c'est un pivot un mec qui est attendu
d'eux qu'ils sautent et qu'à son nez qui
osent écouter ses coûts n'y est pas
c'est qu'au niveau des champions
l'incroyable vol mais en fait c'est plus
des joueurs comme reach pas la mêlée
signé plusieurs gros potentiel comme
t'es acheté l'été en fait il ya deux et
il a fini aux lakers très bon choix et
acheter exact très beau choix
mais du coup ça va mal à la deuxième
question ces dernières années les lakers
ont drafté excellemment bien sûr les
fans du premier tour début du second bon
les cous moi allez zou batch et l'art in
health est un roseau même sans le bac se
charge suite je charte absolument d'une
charte
est ce que on imaginait lakers surfer ce
type de couches saison moi je dis c'est
possible il ya dix ans il y aura des et
dans tout ce que tu as cité c'est
marrant parce que c'est quand même des
joueurs qui étaient déjà un peu confirmé
à part peut-être cozma mais sinon c'est
des joueurs qui étaient plus valeurs
sûres que dd freshmen etc moussa peut
être pas mal en tout cas ça va défendre
sur sur le meilleur garde adverse avec
avec les les mains les mains qui tape au
sol et l'intimidation tu vas tu connait
enfin david mitchell servi à une chose
mais il est de sunu al'avantage de
mesurer bien douce 13 cm de plus je
pense
il a montré des choses intéressantes en
termes de leadership et compagnie et ce
qui il faut quand même et je pense pour
jouer à côté d'eux mais quand lebron
james il faut quand même avoir un
un petit quelque chose en plus sûre sur
ce plan là et moi j'ai bien aimé ce
qu'il a fait cette année globalement
c'est pas c'est pas grave c'est pas des
collants à du côté de l'illinois sa
fighting absolument absolument
quelqu un bon plan pour pour tom est ce
qu'ils sont capables de bien draft et
les lakers cette année avec leur choix
ce magentis perte et la imagine qu'ils
se portaient la bassée qui se perd tu es
là c'est tous les jours qui se perd tome
c'est c'est plus de 40% à 3 points sur
quatre ans de carrière n 6 2 m je pense
qu'un scooter spécialistes cela manquait
un peu à l'écart pendant le moment un
spécialiste et reese et parle de tuer
andy capable de tirer et défendre mais
avec moi se shooter spécialistes
je trouve l autre je vais là tu prend
absolument aucun risque sur l'état
d'esprit sur le baby basket sur ces
choses là tu te prends un peu
défensivement mais derrière comme tu dis
c'est un spécialiste un spécialiste
pardonne des choses des gars comme doit
donc même duarte
kispert et sur tout et sur tout çà çà çà
çà tour vraiment un mais comme qui se
perdent par exemple ça t'ouvre vraiment
des espaces tu peux pas faire d'impasses
défensive avec deux jours d'épreuves
néanmoins excellent alors de genre on
pourrait dire presque es que ce qu'on
connaît beaucoup de deux roues qui
profile shooter qui y performent
d'ailleurs au dollar à léo qui
finalement sa digue n'a été pas mal si
on a bien chuté 1
ouais après là je veux dire dans les
quotidiennes je ne vais pas sur ventes
qui se perd tu vois par exemple mais là
on parle d'un mec qui est senior qui au
plafond qui a fait ses quatre ans tu as
une maturité que tu aura peut-être pas
forcément chez un joueur spécialiste
mais qui serait juste situe après un ou
deux ans à mon avis quatre ans dans une
bonne école
il va peut-être pas journée à
saint-jouan 2%
non non c'est sûr c'est sûr tu dois
garder le pic un spécialiste je pense
peut vraiment gardrat il y aurait
peut-être dû très murphy aussi qui est
spécial soutien qu'a vraiment fait que
ça virginia pour le coup qui se perte il
a fait un peu de transition très murphy
gelé surtout vu prendre du catch and
shoot mais c'est vrai que ça
peut-être d'un profil comme ça qui pour
qui tu peux monter de trois systèmes iff
dj riddick
bon évidemment qui peut aussi l'idéal
américain est sur le terrain on joue
pour ses qualités quoi c'est vrai
qu'elle a aujourd'hui tu as honte à
lacanau et pocket surperformer vente
dans la bulle mais t'as pas ce type de
profil quoi je vois passer du duncan
robinson en commentaires mais je vais
lui met en garde m certes les pas d'un
ken robinson déjà parce qu'il est plus
petit en fait mais mais dans l'idée
pourquoi pas en fait des choses qu'on ne
sait jamais mais comme comme johnson a
aidé une rotation comme phoenix en lice
et sa deuxième année au quai après moi
je fais c'est toujours des joueurs un
peu plus grand c'est plus facile d'avoir
un spotter quand il est plus grand parce
que bat là-bas la balle part de plus
haut etc
je vais je vais laisser libéré romain
qui est qui était en otage comme la
vidéo l'indiquent ces derbys nez c'est
bon matthieu vrilliard
merci contre 1,6 pour la gueule ding wen
vendredi puis va merci tout le monde
merci aux gens qui posent les
commentaires sur les côtés c'est
intéressant c'est interactif c'est sympa
reppion on continue puisque les stations
comme un poids santé classique
monsieur savoir si bien chez faire aussi
bien ce sera difficile pour essayer
beaucoup âge
merci beaucoup à bientôt installer tout
le monde a plus tôt mais ce que tu as
une autre question à nous poser est
absolument absolument et donc du coup je
me posais l'autre question m il a un peu
posé en imaginant pourquoi pas en
arrière mais je me posais la question de
ce que les lakers notre brave total ans
ou un profil particulier ou voir un
poste particulier parce que un profil
peut-être un shooter mais sur un poste
en particulier ce que vous voyez en 3
comble et réponse réponse m je vais au
feat
ils sont aussi l'exemple sauf si un mec
des centraux
oui oui mais après tu es dans une équipe
qui vise le titre se développer c'est
pas forcément leur europe tient-il
premier donc moi je vais au mieux cette
coupe c'est le couple et les deux mais
je pense qu un créateur un mec je dis
pas que tu peux remplacer un mec comme
rondeau l'avait été dans la bulle mais
ça manque un peu aux lakers andrew bynum
mec sans lebron capable de générer de
l'attaqué
c'est dur de trouver en vente pour ce
qui mais si j'avais un profil serait
peut-être ça alors tomtom g&g pascal
gibert nez qui est qui était alors dans
le live qui me dit qui rapporte les
paroles d'un scalp des lakers
alors dit on a besoin de quelqu'un qui
nous est tout de suite et il y en a pas
beaucoup
voilà même impression jet à moi c'est
clair et c'est ça que ça change un peu
de d'habitude puisque quand on l'a on
faisait la liste des bonnes draft des
bons joueurs draftés d'art saison par
les lakers c'est des gars qui sont
devenus bons dans des dans un schéma où
il avait un peu de temps de jeu où il
est pas trop d'ambition ou derrière
lebron
on va dire le coude mac qui a performé
entre guillemets mais de trouver un
joueur qui performent maintenant avec un
fin de premier tour mais il faut quand
même trouver le bon gars qui fit à
lebron bien quand même vachement de avec
les chantiers qu'on connaît je trouve
que la tâche allait vachement déficit
atteint n'ont effectivement pas facile
effectivement pas facile est ce que vous
avez d'autres noms à proposer qui sont
pour vous vraiment nba ready parce qu'il
ya ce qu'on dit à une bière et deep ya
ceux qui le sont duarte qui se heurte
aux verts déjà rainbow teneur ouais
wisques ample mais c'est trop robin
s'énerve way désuet des genres plus
vieux déjà spécialiste d'un truc qui
était fort nsia parce qu'en face c'était
moins bon mais qui en nba vont pouvoir
soit mettre des tyrans et un petit peu
défendent en sortie de banc soit je pars
protéger le cercle et finir proche du
panier en attaque soit créé un petit peu
d'attac nationale et landon nationale je
le prends au lakers mans tous ces noms
vous tapez sur le site envergure il ya
les scouts une report on n'a pas le
temps de vous faire les profils ici
maintenant évidemment mais mais mais si
vous voulez prendre le temps si vous
avez 5 minutes généralement cinq minutes
de lecture ça suffit / / envergure point
c ou pour le profil effectivement il ya
plusieurs plusieurs profils nba ready
tom toi tu poser la question au début
est ce que toi tu penses que tu que les
lakers vont drafté où est-ce qu'ils y
vont ils vont trade et chercher de
l'aide pour la une des ders de lebron
prochain ouais on soit crois que c'est
clair je pense qu'ils l'ont drafté quand
même je me fie aux dernières saisons les
lakers leur salaire de leur tenir à
coeur de d'avoir des jeunes drafté des
jeunes du sérail des mecs qui sont là
depuis longtemps je pense qu'avec qui
vont de racheter après ce qui est sûr
que les lakers et que l'opportunité fera
aussi leur draft ils sont aussi capables
de bazarder certains gars pour monter si
l'on a vu quelque chose où justement
pour rechercher du vétéran donc c'est
aussi ça la force des lakers et qu'ils
ont une peur de rien lâcher cinq jeunes
au prince charles anthony davis ça se
fait donc donc voilà je pense que c'est
beaucoup d'incertitudes en fait et est
ce que dit rien de ce que nous disait
pascal c'est la même sensation
soit ils ont ils voient quelqu'un ils
ont vu quelqu'un qui peut apporter tout
de suite
soit on peut imaginer un trade rapidos
d'ailleurs j'ai vu le toit alex de tu ne
dis pas mais toi tu vas aller chercher
notre espagnol gérer la foule
bamba yacouba tu as me salue que tu as
lu dans ton dans ma grotte d'un hamac
bah moi je trouve pas ça idiot de m
garou pas aux lakers
même si je pense qu'un spécialiste c'est
mieux mais mais je trouve que c'est le
règne en fait s'il arrive à ce niveau là
et que là il a performé un peu sur son
premier match j'ai eu un truc comme ça
les lakers ils vont se dire qu'il fit
avec plus ou moins lebron et guy quand
même bah garuba il va un peu partout en
fait c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
peut-être le joueur le plus n'diaye
ready de la draft en vrai
au delà de kate en chinois sont bien sûr
pas le vécu en europe
c'est ça à preuve le mec il a fait ses
preuves en euroligue donc tu peux le
mettre tranquille sur le terrain mbia
quoi tu auras pas de morrisburg c'est
pas pour autant que mon ce succès non
non non parce qu'il sait pas tirer qui
est qu'ils progressent très peu en fait
pour ça mais bon même franchement --et
c'est sûr qu auteur mes amis de finale
tu n'as pas beaucoup de faux ça peut
servir pour mettre des grosses vagues le
bouquet tome est ce que tu peux nous
dire quel sera le programme de la nuit
de jeudi à vendredi et après on passe je
sais plus de qui on parle après orlando
choix absolument alors leur cible on
sera ensemble qui aura à la manu des
toilettes on sera tous ensemble la draft
devrait débuter vers 1h30 donc je pense
qu'on va prendre une demi heure avoir
peut-être une heure avant d'ailleurs
beaucoup mais pour répondre à un maximum
de questions pour justement reparler de
certains prospects parce qu'une fois que
adam des boules on voit plus le temps
passe et ça va très très vite donc on se
retrouvera tous ensemble sur steam pour
une belle une belle nuit de draft
effectivement on ira jusqu à la fin d'un
film à l'autre il n'y a pas de français
pour aller pour aller plus loin mais ce
serait déjà pas mal
tu vois là l'idée c'est quand même de
s'amuser ensemble qu'ils nous fassent y
découvrir un maximum de profils
différents et puis on les découvrira
rapidement c'est un signal qui semble
aussi et puis on se je pense que ce sera
encore l'occasion d'avoir des idées des
phases marrant comme elle qu'ailleurs 0
il ya deux ans qui restera dans les
annales quand même y croire quand même
en deux ans et reste rétrospectivement
peut-être qu'on dira qu'on n'avait pas
d'armé
et voilà ce que je veux faire mais donc
s'entendre sur twitter twitter voilà
bastia jeudi obtenons gt2 pas si
longtemps le gars c'est un plaisir
bon courage bonne soirée merci toi signe
bons messieurs est ce que vous êtes
prêts pour une moc draftexpress est ce
qu'on est prêt pour une moc draftexpress
je suis injuste en 10 secondes je
réponds une personne 4 connaît tous la
même question sur pourquoi de jeunes du
zinc ne s'est pas présente à la droite a
wave asie parce qu'il est mauvais non
non il a fini par coûter man parce que
il a testé il a testé sa cote
et puis il a pas eu de bons retours
qu'ils pensaient aussi de juger il veut
être grâce au premier tour et qu'on n'y
a pas dit qu'ils le seraient ils pensent
que c'est cependant réussi à l'oeil pour
elle il pourrait augmenter sa cote cela
peut être vrai ça peut être beau mais je
pense que c'est pour ça que j'ai appris
tout cas ça peut faire un bon duo avec
un art e-bay l'année prochaine louis
fauré qui reste quatre ans par contre il
arrive c'est pas ni prochaine non c'est
payton watson monde attend ce jour rien
l'histoire heroes tyler héros c'est
juste qu'on avait rigolé bien fort lors
de sa draft et comeau
on s'était fait critiquer après sertir
band saison après sa première bonne
saison à miami
on l'attendait pas si tôt et en fait on
se moquait de lui parce qu'il y avait
des petits bras ah ouais comme sa vie
parce qu'on aime pas les jours ses
petits bras les gars est-ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une mode graphique
express par l'obésité flammes c'est à
dire que vous aurez 15 secondes pour
choisir donc j'espère que vous avez vos
board sous les yeux chacun là ça va
aller vite
ça va aller vite ça va tourner j'espère
que vous êtes allé y est alternée pic
genre ben allal mouais ça ça veut dire
la même chose
ok c'est cool ok je vais commencer par
alan j'ai fait un petit plouf
alan pique un des trois c'est parti
taking off 4 canning âme en peine
houston pic de we love green
john green en deux manu scott barnes
barnes en 3 au 4 donc ouais bah je suis
me borne aux quatre toronto et voile
mobley ah oui votre mobile est du coup
c'est fou ce qui se passe et va vous
donne l'opportunité à bas at on nourrit
h conte pâture n'auront pas la table là
je suis sur cinq
johnson je prends à geelong par exemple
leurs adjoints
bah oui challen 505 à orlando à 6
oklahoma mozy ce maudit mosese moody en
7 à golden state james goodnight score
de uconn tonight ben à 8 à orlando à
nouveau ben laden commises à comines
gars à orlando en plus de bosses pas mal
plus de suuns man your man u à
sacramento kings johnson johnson alan
pour memphis du coup de rugby tient
jeudi 10 en dix bennes 11 je crains à
charlotte jackson au j'adore ça
à charlotte pour recevoir des groupes de
la mélo bol ça m'excite manu en 12 à san
antonio
j'hésite mais je vais aller petite
surprise qu'hayden springer jayden
springer hockey un petit arrière de plus
à san antonio
mais il sait tout faire jaden 13 pays
soeur à la can commence à l'issue
cameron thomass du scoring pour
l'épaisseur 14 golden state ben crâne
wagner à ouidah l'action france
il était là il est et il es t il il est
là encore effectivement et pour g bâle
15 wizards manu je sais qu'ils vont
faire de la merde
donc on va leur mettre un gars qui prend
pas du tout dans leur truc alperine
semoun halpern senghor il ya la place
pour lui
16 hockey si kyle jones
kyle jones ok donc ils ont eu beaucoup
night déjà ça tu vois les choses
non je leur ai mis quoi je crois que ça
sinon j'avais j'ai mes bouquins et aux
warriors semoun manier leur ami louis
moody djoudi et kyle jones - 17 17 ben
du coup new new orleans conneries qu'ils
portent
ok 18 encore ok si et manu cette fois
corric isaiah todd asa et tod
ok ok ok 19 onyx alan j'arrive cooper et
c'est bien trop bas j'arrive cooper et
c'est bien trop bas 20 à atlanta t'auras
pas le droit en x men johnson johnson
hockey de potentiels avant tout knicks
man u 21 allégé faire plaisir à ben
jawad butler jarrett butler pour du
scoring assuré sur les bases arrières 22
lakers à la crise ajouté
ok les roquettes en 23 et 24 d'abord ben
ensuite manu williams their willems 1 23
et 1 24 manu on appuie en 2010 qui dort
ok editor 25 équipes earth pour allan a
très mal
très mal ok 26 les pépites de denver
ben murphy le grand de virginia qui
shoote 27 honnête
manu correctrices porte il devait déjà
mais un phoque la vienne mitchell est
toujours là et bien on va aller pas avec
joe white groupes terroristes comme ok
d'un croc rionnaise 28h routier tout ce
qu'il leur faut
28 deviennent mitchell ou pas c'est chez
qui ces chéquiers cette fois six heures
6 heures nationale en national en 29
phoenix ben 30 jazz man u yahia n'a pas
été brillant si si si il a des roquettes
aller à roland ries hockey et donc ont
glissé t vienne mitchell clairement
médias boston budget boston n'est pas la
tâche christopher jardin rumba ou cela
ousmane dia rumba népal a senti aldama
n'est pas la romieu weems mais on sait
que mal seul du bit un frère joël à yayi
n'est pas là est notre ami
greg brown and les gars y vend ni les 50
dans tout les mots quand c'est chaud
c'est chaud ben je te libères yes man u
aussi je te libère ou pas bat a fini la
non non j'ai pas fini j'ai encore plein
mais banon je me lève on essaye de vous
faire la suite de la draft en podcast et
pour avoir ben avec nous salut manu à
jeudi pour la draft huriez sa cime
évidemment que ce menu
bon alors alan se laisse prendre les
questions sociales chatte points alors
voilà nous y sommes voilà me tu penses
quoi de coupure je pense que c'est un
des meilleurs formateurs de la draft
c'est un incroyable passeur et il faut
pas prendre pour argent comptant sont
simples pourcentage à 3 points en ciel
pour dire que c'est un mauvais shooter
et pourcentage aux lancers francs
viennent montrer qu'il a un toucher un
assez bon toucher puis comme alex la vie
dans son soutien rapporte envergure que
vous pouvez allez voir c'est un bien
meilleur shooter dans les catégories
inférieures donc c'est pas pour ça que
ça parce qu'il a tout le temps tu trop
très mal shooté set cette année à auburn
que ça m'aurait shooter mais c'est un
succès un super jarius trop petit mais
c'est un super joueur
alors est ce qu'on a comme thomas c'est
parti jérémie oui je les fait partir en
loterie à indiana je crois de mémoire
ces gens que j'ai donc je crois beaucoup
à se voir là non plus pour moi c'est un
genre loterie alan qui sera le premier
français pic jeudi soir
boum hue qui arrive vas-y vas-y en soi
mais c'est la meilleure voie du foot
français çà va être qu'ils soient
françaises et autres piques jeudi à
dents je pense que ça sera jeune béguin
je vais prendre d'autres questions alors
attends je vais d'avion shay qui est là
merci tu désolé on est à la bourre de ou
pas de soucis salut les gars ça va merci
d'être là
shay est ce que je peux toujours dire de
rivers situé créé tout bien sûr
ouais ouais bien sûr plus que jamais
juste que jaja sks qu'est un mook qui
sort bientôt
on vient de sortir un mook sur chicago
que vous pouvez voir derrière moi et
puis il y en aura d'autres à venir dans
les mois qui viennent évidemment
alors justement dans la dans la dans le
chat on dit orlando dit nous tous on
était là pour parler d' orlando chat je
t'ai dit oui arrive avec une hotte tech
ou arrive avec une question vas-y alors
on va dire que je suis plus dans la
spéculation que dans l'arc dans la hotte
tech mais j'aime et je veux bien votre
avis là-dessus vu que je pense qu'on dit
d'accord pour dire que qu orlando n'a
pas de franchise player ou deux joueurs
qui donnent l'impression de pouvoir
l'être à court ou à moyen terme et qu'on
parle d'une draft qui n'a a priori pas
de franchise player
au delà du top 2 ou 3 même si je me
trompe est ce que ça vaut pas le coup de
passer un petit coup de fil à une équipe
comme comme denver en proposant les pics
de 5 et 8 qui au premier tour plus un
joueur comme john entonna isaac et
d'essayer de choper un michael porter
junior par exemple qui va être
restricted free-agent intéressant la vie
d'alan et hull après c'est
malheureusement vous attabler à la place
si moi j'ai toujours ensemble je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de joueur qui peut être
franche espère donc après tu peux
toujours ouverte à d énormes potentiels
qui peuvent se révéler être mais qui ont
en fait des déplanchés niveau plancher
plus bas donc ça peut être le plus plus
probable dit que si ça marche pas on
voit la question moi je moi j'aurai moi
j'aimerais monter si j'étais vous c'est
à dire qu'avec la première chose que
j'ai vue après la loterie c'était pas
possible de monter dans le top 4
peut-être même plus tôt je pense que je
pense pas que michael porter vos hôtes
en réalité je pense que je pense je
pense que tu peux l'avoir pour un peu
moi mais ce qui est sûr je pense c'est
que de rares fera par le prochain
franchise player option numéro un du
magic qui t'amène en finale de conf à
l'est dans cette race je pense pas mais
que tu peux avoir c'est l'an prochain en
étant soi nul sonné donc tu serais
partisan de
de construire de continuer à former un
noyau dur avec tête en une séance épique
là où on entend un petit peu quoi ouais
je pense que je ne referai des joueurs à
fort potentiel
si tu perds l'année prochaine dans un
jeune et un nouveau coach qui a été
nommé il ya une nouvelle structure il ya
eu
moi j'ai vraiment apprécié ce qui s'est
passé à la deadline du coup d'être icade
orlando je les dis ouais il fallait
voilà le l'objectif de mon frigo et the
big au sportpaleis et c'était juste de
le faire c'était de faire les play offs
et d'être compétitif tu as une équipe
qui elle qui était une belle équipe
saison régulière mais n'avait pas de
potentiel en réalité et c'est dur de ce
l'admettent mais c'est courageux de ce
laps de l'admettre mais orlando après ce
choix-là courageux récupérer les jeunes
ils sont quand même lâché fourni et
gordon et vous savez de ces normes
sévères un vrai tournant ils ont fait ce
choix là après je pense qu'on va lancer
pour ba viser les playoffs dans est très
compétitif dans quatre ans ça va passer
pour des points le souci c'est que
l'historique récente draft du magic est
pas en fait autant par malchance pour
certains joueurs avec comme comme à
illzach qui je pense était le bon le bon
choix à faire mais kaka pas encore eu de
chance avec les blessures et quand tu
regardes depuis sur l'ère post dwight
howard c'est très très dur lier les
choses graves du magic que ce soit des
joueurs draftés puis échangé tout de
suite comme sabonis qui deviennent all
stars ou des joueurs qui tiennent le sar
plus tard comme oladipo où déjà plus de
chance on va dire c'est vraiment tu t'en
demande 2 dans la draft ouf c'est
peut-être maman bonne tout haut des dix
dernières années
t'as pas trop de chance après tu fais
les erreurs et marie-louise honiara des
choses comme ça mais c'est parce que tu
as fait des erreurs aventure allait
refaire milite pour cent les idées sont
souvent bonne c'est pas parce que le ça
se passe mal ensuite que l'idée de base
et les mauvaises relations
s'ils prennent un parce que là la halle
consensus air de prendre l'air d'être de
prendre un mec comme comme barnes ça
irait bien avec la philosophie draft
orlando des dernières années en plus de
prendre des voix là des longs mais qui
est capable de défendre plusieurs
positions
sur le papier c'est excitant mais est-ce
que ce que c'est pas encore un énième
un énième prospects avec ses
caractéristiques l'aeca des défauts qui
sont dures à gommer quoi on peut en
parler je pensais nazis il connaît très
très bien ce qu'on demande c'est à ce
que dont on lui dit des temps lui était
au plus haut
très c'est avoir un auto type je vais
pas dans les actes qui vient des
séminoles ce jeu reste mauvignier là je
pense que ce serait dit tout est bien la
part du magic de prendre ce côté hockey
la connexion est très mauvaise et
s'excuse pour ceux qui écoutent mais
mais on accompagne généralement c'est la
campagne ma wii
qu'est-ce que si on aille à pierre qui
nous a rejoint pierre oui bonsoir
messieurs comment tu vas by très bien
très bien merci je suis désolé pierre
évident éminemment éminent n'importe
quoi les membres de la data team est
aussi contributeurs à café crème sport
exactement fall et le savez c'est bien
et puis pourquoi vendre notre produit
avec hugues underdogs qui a paru cette
année on parle des pépites qui sont très
très très très très loin dans dans
l'époque mais donc qu'il faut parler on
a tous un peu neuneu foudre c'est très
sympa absolument et des joueurs qui
finiront sans doute pro ailleurs qu'aux
états unis s'ils n'y sont pas et qui se
rendent de très bons pros pour la
plupart est-ce que tu as un avis sur la
draft orlando pierre moi je pense qu
orlando ils vont se diriger un petit peu
ça va être le ok si de l'est c'est
d'ailleurs une espèce de fermat talent
ils vont essayer de
pendant quelques années des cumuls et
les pics comme ça qu'ils feront tri un
peu après moi je vois l'idée un peu
comme ça après s'être ou pas du tout
qu'ils vont faire rollins aura besoin
d'un fort joueur comme chaillol le
sous-entendait mais moi je pense que ça
ils vont être un petit peu dans ce mode
la com com moqué ici ils vont accumuler
les talents à qui quand ils auront le
bon et ben ils construiront autre donnée
intéressante ça y est ce que tu es ce
que tu veux rebondir ou poser une autre
question
non mais du coup on parlait de la
possibilité de monter est ce que c'est
un scénario crédible et scali des
équipes au-dessus qu'un intérêt à lâcher
son pic pour bat pour sa bourse pour les
5 et 8 dans cette draft la cua c'est ça
que c'est simplement parce que là mon
réflexe a été de me dire bon est-ce que
c'est pas mieux d'essayer de viser un
joueur malade je prêche pour sa michael
porter d'une heure parce qu'il a le
potentiel offensif pour peut-être pour
être franche et player c'est peut-être
un peu on s'avance un peu mais voilà je
me demandais si c'est une équipe qui
selon vous avez avait intérêt à
récupérer ses piques 5 et 8 dans cette
draft mais en particulier ça dépend qui
glisse en 5 c'est toujours la même chose
là on a vu même fils grimper en dise ça
veut dire qu'ils ont des échos ça veut
dire qu'ils pensent qu'un joueur dont
ils sont amoureux sera disponible en 10
mai qu'il l'était pas qu'il l'aurait pas
été en dix-sept puisqu'il s'était 17
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose de
similaire qui peut se tramer avec
orlando 5 et 8 en fête battait sûr
d'avoir ou coming out barnes ou sexe
voire 2 et 3 ça va dépendre de comment
tu classe les joueurs je sais pas si toi
tu les classes tous dans le même dans le
même potentiel dans le même tiers comme
on dit aussi si tu si tu fais des
différences c'est ce que j'aimerais bien
les mixer s'il peut chuter en cinq mois
après je suis un peu triste pour marquer
le funk
j'étais heureux de le voir vivre un port
lan do je trouvais qu'il avance avant sa
grave blessure il y avait quand même un
super début de saison mais bon si son
avenir physique est pas garantie seul ce
qui a été un leader à gonzaga ça me
plaît bien
pour l'instant il n'a pas été vu par
rolande en tout cas dans ce qui est
sorti on n'a aucune info sur ce texte
fait par orlando et 5e en 2d plus et il
a vu qu'ils règlent parce que du coup je
te dis serait il n'a pas vu toronto il
n'a pas vu orlando après parce que son
agent il filtre rien même à shirley gros
truc où tu vois beaucoup de choses tu
vois sur les gros noms et il apparaît
pas pour l'instant orlando il aurait vu
mosys midi pyréenes johnson küng à deux
fois
ça serait donc on revoit bout 5 et 8 6
que ming est pas en d2 choix du métier
que je serais très surpris ouais facile
disons qu'ils sont en gros il glissera
pas après 8
on va peut-être arriver ce qu'un jeune
c'était son propre processus de
reconstruction peut il sera pas bon l'an
prochain donc il ne cédera pas être bon
il pourra même tva temps est mauvais ça
peut être pas négatif pour rendre alors
pour ceux qui nous regardent encore
d'âge à mersin jeu ou ensuite abonnez
vous et troisièmement on va parler doc
et si donc un dixième des pics de cette
draft
juste après mais avant on va faire un
quiz chailly cité show allait le rester
avec nous pour le quizz tiers a préparé
un quizz sur où les anecdotes des
provençaux alors là là vous allez
pouvoir briller en société
derrière prochaine il ya un peu de tout
on va pas se mentir bien que tout j'ai
essayé de faire des deuxièmes assises un
peu rouverts à lire alors première
question depuis quand la draft nba tels
deux tours il ya des années 80 ça c'est
le début daiane 2e 87 n'ont peut-être
plus il ya plus longtemps peut-être
quelque chose comme soixante quinze
jours a dit non c'est dans les années 80
je vous ai dit c'est pas le mieux bien
et cette fois non 80 ans déjà les 80 ans
du premier coup après faisait quoi avec
je te laisse tes le chef question numéro
deux quais tuning être numéro 11 de la
prochaine draft
certainement quel est le joueur des
cowboys de au clam aux states jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est que smart avoir été
drafté le plus au parc usmar ton sens
non pourquoi attend est-ce que c'est
serré serré sens est suffisamment récent
pour qu'on trouve nom pareil c'est pas
très récent ces milieux de 90 j'étais
pas né s qui travaillent sur était
maintenant ils espionnent par gadji
espionne je crois pas s'agissant du pôle
2 y'a pas longtemps ça un pivot j'ai pas
j'aurai beau flop friends no big country
à braintree ouais ça y est vous avez
plus qu il était question numéro 3
quel est le prénom complet de dawson ou
le prospect de hanoi
ouais c'est un truc nigérian quoi ah
[ __ ] j'ai lu il faut le deuxième os il
fallait toujours pas bah oui pour les
deux non je ne triche pas rentrer je les
passais un f le deuxième non non c'est
un commence par la cus et quang ninh hai
au pot faisait zéro pour tout le monde
ça ça ça va aller vite normalement
qu'elle prospère pour demi frère
l'ancien rookie of the year marcuse
excuses merci
alertés les poils elle peut se faire
siffler ou des garanties
désolé c'est pas grave qu elle prospecte
à une soeur jour actuellement du rnb par
les coupeurs fabriquer un jeu ajout
sport ex oasis et sa bataille c'était un
couple mais ouais c'était en coupe uefa
et toi qui est branché basket féminin
elle elle est toujours avec dwight
howard pana est sûr c'est que ça fait
quelques mois qu'ils sont séparés mais
alors on continue
un prospect de cette cuvée un demi frère
qui a joué en nhl qui est il si je sais
je sais que le canadien peut-être je
sais qu'ici on en a parlé en plus avec
brawn s'annonce quinting rhymes
exactement quand même bien joué et le
joueur c'était là leur meilleur score
aux sabres de buffalo à vancouver et
winnipeg
je réponds juste askri knox il se porte
dans le tchat
c'est jeudi soir la draft on sera en
live sur twitter j'ai la force team
question muros est qu elle prospecte
connu pour avoir couru le 100 m en 10
secondes 6 kyle jones
non non attends je te tuerais cosim ce
que johnson ou là je confonds to be 06
non pas 10 06 n'ont dit si ces 70 60
la même 10 60 c'est beau tu peux aller
très vite comme ça jason springer dont
il va passer vite
qui va penser second tour de draft n
drafted quelques conférences et si ici
un forcément
la conférence est à la débrouille et
sofia smart et non un troll ou riffs la
mais lui il aurait dû aller aux jo j'ai
toujours dit et leur au moins une
qualité c'est au numéro 8 qu'elle
prospère pour idole zaza pachulia jimmy
qualifie 10,60 roman waugh karim wade à
andrew dans le bouquet janvier j'ai fait
des minois seront dédiés à nashville
hissait en plus il entra de fer des
routes partout donc je sens qu'ils
voient partout loeb s'est redit jeudi
je vais donc mam ou quel âge billy qui
on va parler ne sais pas si nico est
encore debout
c'est pas être sacramento ca ne
s'échouent chaud question numéro 9
qu'elle prospère américain est né au
japon toujours des mecs comme ça comme
ses fils de militaire dia comme ceux qui
sont nés en allemagne les unitaires
exactement c'est pas williams non c'est
sa mère qui est militaire
ah [ __ ] j'ai lu un article tout à
l'heure si j'ai vu chaque et ben k comme
thomas ce week-end thomass ah ouais
ouais
ken thompson le moment qui a l'air
d'être assez haute en couleur aussi
voilà un petit bézy undefeated a confié
quel est le vrai prénom de ji qui tord
joe jack jack couac du fanum c'est
soudanais exactement un sud sudan et pas
comme comme time matters le même joueur
qui est sur différents mission numéro
qu'elle prospère et saison arrêt réalisé
le deuxième triple double de l'histoire
de sa fac
le deuxième d'un jeu made mitchell non
alors mais c'est une grosse qu'on reste
ouais c'est une grosse ronfle c'est une
grosse course un bon programme
c'est pas ses pages aux seniors zhang a
dit jean royer liste c'était le premier
league
ah ouais alors un à dix ans après après
brook lopez c'est le programme standford
du coup c'est à dire c'est un oui mais
le dunk à deux mains comme cela il met
en relief un triple double ouais en
transition et mais un écran moulin à
vent le monde pense moi je cherchais un
prospect de règles j'allais dire duarte
est alors la dernière question après
sera des joueurs mystère iv prospects
déclaré hu à bloc pour santé supérieure
à 10 keith johnson jackson ouais ouais
inspire il m'en foutais rien d'autre
kyle jones non non dit ricco sims et
voix de mobley non non non pas
supérieure à 10
charles massi way 11 12 5
jackson ses 12 points 8 c'est le
deuxième listons ce nom ah ouais mais
c'est des grands qu'on connaît pas après
ça aussi si si si si jerry chris simms
nom des rangs de sharp non plus vous
pensez européen qui joue à thiais france
d'un coup il dit
wagner non notre français un portugais
parce que cette seule pensée et qui
était assez le premier et après penser
virginie des sdf qui à 11,9
ce match on est vraiment le le plusieurs
alors après je vous ai préparé des
joueurs mystères il ya vous me dites il
a un défi qu des moyennes 1 difficulté
assez corte et l'autre qui est super
super dur où elle qu'elle avait fait
graduellement ses opéras du helmand
vas-y julien lepers
je commence à pas mort et que vos
étoiles je te dise 'on a battu peut
démissionner ça
alors je suis né en 2000 j'étais
sophomore cette année c'était l'idée
dans mon équipe en point et un robot
j'ai un pourcentage de rebond défensif
de 21 2 2me rebonds offensifs de 8,6 un
pourcentage turn over de 11,8
je mesure deux mètres 06
jones non mon coach et parfois dans les
rumeurs pour un poste en nba
gérard marian robinson heures exactement
ça y est je joue en big east
donc ça c'était le premier hommage à cet
homme simple ça ouais j'sais plus sage
et plus simple alors on enchaîne je suis
junior j'étais le capitaine de mon
équipe cette saison je fais 118 kg j'ai
un ratio à sister lovers 2 1 tout rond
je marque et 11,08 points par match
j'avais 20,1 en pourcentage de défensif
deux rebonds défensifs pardon derek
éleveurs non en pourcentage
d'interception je suis à 2006
j'ai un trou shooting de 58,2 nous
aiderait de 23,5
je jouais si si je suis classé 54e ou
top 100 qui espionne je joue pour les
florida state séminal raekwon grecque et
la particularité d'avoir une majuscule
vingt deux majestueux son prénom avec
sûr j'aurais apprécié sa toujours là
toujours le c'est le petit plus c'est
pour la online team bien évidemment
alors le joueur très très dur on y va je
fais un mais 80 18 pour cent kilos je
suis gaucher je suis senior
j'ai un pourcentage d'interception de
3,8 et retailer non j'ai un pourcentage
d'assises de bonne foi
j'ai un pourcentage de rebond de 17 8
j'ai un usage reigt de 24,7 un
pourcentage de blob de 5,4 mon frère
joue aussi en collège basket ball
maystadt les plus significatives 16,1
points et un affreux 56 6 % aux lancers
francs
homo rui grosse mist non je joue dans
une eau mehdorn
j'ai 24 ans révolus je ne suis pas dans
le top 100 et spl ma fac est situé à
baltimore dans le maryland
maintenant je joue à copine state face
cayla anthony task et dark
ouais c'était super bien c'est juste des
candidats y retourner par mail à 24 ans
ont la couenne et cette fac juste parce
que c'était le premier match de quête de
la saison johnson à wiesen johnson
merci beaucoup pierre mais derrière sa
peau au cou pour briller en société
anthony tard c'est pas mal on est là je
le connaissais avant tout le monde quand
il joue en d2 italienne
ça y est ce que tu as d'autres questions
ou d'autres affirmations une révision je
reste sur mon idée que c'est pas
impossible que le magic bouge pour pour
un joueur plus que pour un prospect mais
je pense que c'est plus ce que j'espère
que que ce que ce qui va vraiment se
passer mais voilà on espère hockey et
ben écoute on s'en rappellera on fera du
coup quand michael porter junior sera
austère avec orlando les prochaines
lorsqu'on se rappelle royalties merci
chers de rien et merci à rivers pour
pour le taf que vous faites
merci merci pour tout le taf aussi les
gars c'est normal
merci beaucoup a plus merci d'être assis
tard c'est quoi la chao salut alors les
gars on va parler doc et si dans
quelques poignées de secondes quand
j'aurai eu le temps d'envoyer le le lien
de quelle équipe on n'a pas parlé
simplement les cagots tu vas qui à
chicago est en très bon cran de suite je
pense que ça peut être sûr ecosim
skipper vu qu'on l'à beaucoup aimé en
voir cote
et moi j'aimerais bien yves mais ce sera
je pense dur etc aux sims hockey jerry
cosim 138 ça c'est la grosse cote
on retient évidemment si jamais ça
arrive donc on a simonovic qui revient
donc ouais c'est vrai d'ailleurs haleine
les fans de chicago qui nous écoutent
oui j'avais déjà même en arctique il ya
un an j'étais intéressé au possible
draft-n stoch mieux d'europe 2020 il
avait cette année il a continué à jouer
dans donc un méga soccer bête en ligue
adriatique
tous les matchs ont exprimé sur youtube
donc à tenter ma chance sur youtube donc
c'est très très possible de le regarder
sa retraite sur les tireurs c'est
intéressant je suis pas si vous
m'entendez
on entend très bien sûr c'est ça on va
parler de la franchise qui va drafté
tout le monde c'est clairement ce à
quelques questions tu à nous poser est
ce que tu es j'en ai une qui fait assez
actualité je sais pas si vous avez suivi
pendant la demi voix sarman qui a sorti
eu un tweet comme quoi presti avait fait
une bonne offre pour caïds et que les
pistols avait refusé et on sait depuis
quelques jours ben que presti agressif
mais ça c'est pas trop surprenant on va
dire
et pour moi la question ça sera vous
êtes prêt à lâcher quoi pour ok si si
vous êtes ok si pour monter dans le top
3 je vais pas m 1 parce que ça me paraît
vraiment loin mais pour remonter dans le
top 3 en revue ses différents déjà c'est
pas la même question si tu vois c'est
sûr a obtenu montant 1 us que la
question subsidiaire c'est quoi c'est ce
qu' il faut lâcher shea du coup la
réponse c'est non
qu'est ce que tu vas faire un arrêt
cardiaque donc non fort en fait faut
regarder ce que ce coquet ci a déjà
comme pied c'est ce qu'ils cherchent
autant de talent et ce qu'ils peuvent
avoir en pièces six mois je suis pas
convaincu qu'il faille de survendre pour
essayer d'aider nos stocks 3 mais est-ce
que déjà ok si peut choisir tous les
joueurs qu'ils ont là où est-ce qu'ils
ont pas ils ont pas obligé de faire un
package pour pouvoir justement
descendront de manque deux pics et avoir
assez de joueurs dans le roster pas ne
pas voir trop jour dans le roster
honnêtement on a on a eu plusieurs fois
cette question là nous quand on fait des
vagues au site est assez large parce que
tu as plein de joueurs en option d'un
plein de joueurs avec des contrats non
garantis
donc pour la plupart là dessus tu peux
être large après effectivement tu as
potentiellement 3 avoir quatre joueurs
si tu fais un trade avec les deux pics
du début de second tour qui peuvent être
drafté au premier tour donc ça fait
beaucoup de contrats garantie effective
n'est pas sous contrat ouais ouais ouais
concrètement à nos joueurs sous contrat
auquel bâches etc
mais les cainris williams e gabriel des
cases aérobie tous ces jours là n'ont
pas de contrats garantis en fait vous
presti à la marge de manoeuve là-dessus
d'accord mois après mois je vois pas
pourquoi cleveland a accumulé trop de
jeunes avec trop de pique je vois pas
pourquoi houston le ferai aussi puisque
après quand tu as trop de jeunes tu peux
pas du tout s'est développée donc pour
moi ça arrivera pas je peux me planter
mais pour moi ça remue nombre pierre ton
avis là dessus
ouais je suis un peu je partage l'avis
des u crois que c'est un peu compliqué
c'est un peu le problème qui est que
vont avoir
ok si c'est à dire qu'ils ont accumulé
tellement de pique en plus de ça on va
leur demander beaucoup plus cher de
payer en nombre de pics je pense je
pense que la facture sera sûrement plus
à l'est pour eux que c'est une autre
équipe vu qu'ils en ont plein de dessins
prennent dix ans à venir et donc va pas
retrouver le bon dosage entre guillemets
et aussi le bon client parce que c'est
vrai que tu es plein de jeunes voix pour
des équipes qui ont un peu traîné plus
ambition un papa il n'y a pas de c'est
très très respectueux mais c'est
compliqué quand tu as trop d'eux venu
voir de spa sont enfin pour les équipes
qui arrivent au bout c'est les équipes
qui sont âgés sur papier donc il n'y a
rien de corrélation qui a assez des
sourds à la ils peuvent pique tout le
monde maintenant est-ce qu'ils doivent
le faire ce qu'ils ont fait un package
et pour revenir à la question initiale
de pierre que mettons dans le package
passais et jean jacques pierre et moi on
se connaît assez bien pour parler
souvent de chez russe alexander et se
dire que c'est pas quelqu'un que tu en
as envie de traîner
franchement c'est un moment ils auraient
dû at all star cette année à ce niveau
là donc je traite pas ce jour là après
je pense qu'ils resteront pas en 16es en
18 je pense qu'il devra y vont utiliser
16 et 18 pour monter fin de l'autriche
pense souvent parlé je pense qu'ils
peuvent cibler des équipes peut-être
veulent descendre et avec une belle
offre
je pourrais faire ça mais par contre si
je pense qu'ils vont pique et pour
monter plus haut
je pense qu'il faudrait ça serait c'est
toronto la seule personne qui peuvent
appeler je pense mais je vois pas ce
qu'ils ont fait à toronto
pierre le designer dans le dernier
épisode de son podcast ils n'ont pas de
vétérans offrir en plus d'un pic qui
pourraient être eux qui pourrait plaire
à une équipe à toronto présente tu vois
vous tandis que tu partes couple si par
exemple newton avait été à cette place
peut-être que vous adorez pu envoyer
eric gordon ou christiane woods en plus
dû piquer sa tête fut contenter une
équipe et ils n'ont pas trop en fait
parce que embarqué mbaye thiam bas il
est assez toxique comme contrat dont fut
moi j'ai confiance je pensais que new
orleans est peut-être le chercher kempa
avec le disco du coup il l'envoya même
fils mais je pensais qu'ils allaient
essayer de récupérer kemba d'envoyer
blade soit dame dans l'autre sens mais a
pêché le disent avec est en fait pas du
coup non memphis est allé plus vite
alors j'ai vu kevin o'connor
rapportèrent que je mène fusée encore
monter voilà même si c'est encore monter
donc peut-être qu'ils veulent mode
target s'est c'est +11 moody wagner ils
ont ils sont toutefois mode il aime
beaucoup
ouais cc des pics très métissée les deux
moody et wagner s'est pas sauf ces dépit
que très grise ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai en plus c'est un post post 3
memphis est un peu la ritournelle pour
revenir au thunder
quelle quelle autre question à part ce
trade up tu te poses sur sur cette draft